so we got some protests in New York City
after a homeless man named Jordan nearly
died he was put in a choke hold the man
uh three people were trying to subdue
him and then in the effort to subdue him
the guy died it was ruled the homicide
and now you have protesters calling for
charges of this marine and uh things are
starting to get a little hectic police
are calling for help as things kind of
heat up but we're going to get into the
nuances of that discussion so I'll save
a little bit we do have news out of
Russia they're blaming the U.S for the
assassination attempt so they claim and
uh we've got some news Barstool Sports
fired one of their hosts for rapping
lyrics that that contain an offensive
word I don't necessarily think it's fair
to call what he said a slur because he
wasn't calling anybody the word but you
know he said the word and then pen
entertainment was like you're fired and
now Dave Portnoy is like I don't know
there's nothing I can do I sold the
company so we'll get into that plus a
whole bunch of other stories and um
we'll we'll uh we'll talk about the news
bank's collapsing we got to Paul Stanley
the lead singer I'm sorry the uh front
man for kiss is kind of walking back his
statement on uh transgender kids and uh
a lot to talk about before we get
started my friends today's episode is
brought to you by gas brew coffee take a
look at this bag right here this is cast
brew coffee over at castbrew.com and you
can get your bag of rice with Roberto Jr
and Appalachian nights today by going to
casper.com and with every purchase of
rise with Roberto Jr you will get a
picture of Roberto Jr he's right there
on the back he's our rooster he's very
cool and the coffee smells really good
so if you want to support the show and
support our work go to castbrew.com but
also don't forget to head over to
timcast.com click that join us button to
become a member as a member you'll get
access to the members only uncensored
show which we'll have up for you tonight
at about 10 10 p.m which will be fun
because members actually get an
opportunity to submit questions and
actually call into the show so if you
would like to do that become a member at
at least the 25 level if you've been a
member for at least six months you will
be granted access to submitting these
questions the screening process that we
have so don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Lance from the Surfs thank you
so much for having me it's I'm tripping
balls being in this room right now it
feels like I took evil acid or something
because I've been watching this before
so much yeah just like everything is
here it's wild it's bigger than it looks
like right it's bigger than it looks
like when you're actually sitting in the
room it's actually there's a lot more
props than you ever give this place
credit for I thought there was just like
some samurai swords and like the
occasional gun or something but there's
like if that's a real Civil War rifle
there's a real Civil War musket that's
right rifled musket yeah absolutely
Union Civil War it was uh never used
it's like a museum here cool yeah very
cool stuff uh yeah so so what do you do
who are you uh I am a leftist
commentator I do uh politics comedy from
a dumpster fire perspective and uh I
have opinions and sometimes people like
to hear those opinions and then they
tune in to listen to them well sounds
good I will thanks for joining us I'm
sure we have a lot of opinions to go
through we also got the exact inversion
of Lance Sheamus Coughlin but that's how
they describe me on the streets uh my
name is exactly I thought no they call
him the Auntie Sheamus I thought but my
name's Seamus Coughlin I make cartoons
uh we call them Freedom tunes and he's
British is that why you always got to
take it to an ethnic place with me man
well he's ripping on me for being Irish
I was I was I was born here but
I make cartoons I have a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes I'm also a
podcaster we uploaded a cartoon by today
by the way y'all might want to check
that one out and I also have a stream on
Rumble called shamer if you all wanna
take a peek at that as well now we have
Moon Lord himself I am the moon Lord he
knows no longer weed Lord I have evolved
he knows one with the essence of the
vibration and the fabric of reality so
good to see you Lance and if you don't
know you don't know but I am the moon
Lord let's get hot
uh and I am search.com as always guys
let's get to it let's jump into this
first we we've actually pressing the
wrong button this is I I gotta flag this
this is the first time Ian and I have
done a show together in almost a year I
was yelling at you about religion or
something exactly this is our first show
yeah that's our first welcome back
man yeah I've evolved on my stance we've
also talked off air we we've talked off
air a good bit but it's uh it's just
funny that was like I I just realized
it's our first episode we're both doing
together because I've been seeing you
for the past two weeks yeah yeah we went
last time we talked we're talking about
like I brought advice I was talking
about oh alcohol it's your Vice or
whatever I said I think that was the the
real point of contention and everyone's
like Ian you're such a dick I was like I
was just talking to Sheamus and we were
just talking like we were probably Cyrus
that's racist I don't remember exactly
where it was but I don't really care do
you oh yeah I was just no I was just it
was a discussion about alcohol because I
was saying that alcohol is not
inherently sinful like Christ turned
water into wine it was his first public
Miracle I've gone through blood was made
of wine right I don't know he is trying
substantiation the the properties of
bread and wine remain but it actually
becomes his flesh and blood I've had
like serious problems with alcohol
personally which is probably why I was
projecting issues oh I was just asking
like when you actually eat the blood of
Christ is that Christ is inside you yeah
and then but like his blood is alcoholic
is that why it's wine so the properties
of bread and wine remain but what we
believe is Catholics is that it's his
literal Flesh and Blood okay by his body
blood soul and Divinity so but he's not
made of bread and wine no he's not
literally made her best Get Crunk all
right let's read the news here we go we
also have surgery we already did say
what's up man moon Lord thanks dog all
right here's the story we got this ABC 7
New York Police Issue call for help
outrage continues to grow over deadly
Subway Chokehold encounter say the death
of a Subway Rider who was put into a
Chokehold by a former Marine on the
train has been ruled a homicide and now
activists are calling for charges to be
filed they have planned several protests
and rallies on Thursday as the NYPD had
ish has issued a call for public help in
their investigation Jordan nearly 30
died from a compression of the neck the
city's medical examiner determined
Wednesday Neely is recognizable to some
New Yorkers as a Michael Jackson
impersonator who regularly danced in
Times Square in the Times Square Transit
Hub on Monday afternoon he was yelling
and pacing back and forth on an F train
in Manhattan Witnesses and police said
when he was restrained by at least three
people include including a U.S marine
veteran who pulled one arm tightly
around his neck a physical struggle
ensued leading to nearly losing
Consciousness he was rushed to Lenox
Hill Hospital where he was pronounced
dead on Wednesday a medical exam
determined Neely's uh his death was a
homicide however that does not mean the
case will be prosecuted as a homicide
okay that's the stupidest bit of writing
I've ever heard as a murderer they mean
homicide means death caused by person it
doesn't mean criminal so what they're
trying to say is though the the the
death was worldly homicide it does not
mean the case will be prosecuted as a
murder that is up to the uh Manhattan
day's office which is investigating but
I suppose I'm probably being a little
bit too harsh because you can uh they're
not being clear here you can make the
argument there's Reckless homicide
there's negligent homicide and so what
they're saying is it's not clear that he
will be criminally charged they probably
just should have said they're going to
say as a part of our rigorous ongoing
investigation we'll review the medical
examiner's report assess all available
video and photo footage identify and
interview as many witnesses as possible
and obtain additional medical records
read a statement from a spokesperson for
the D.A so we've got video coming out of
New York protesters uh I believe this
was yesterday we're uh we're seen in the
streets and the police made some arrests
and uh we'll get into it in a little bit
but one of our reporters
was physically assaulted did by one of
the protesters and had his his property
destroyed while he was in the process of
doing journalism but uh uh let's just
let's just get down to Brass tax here
because I'm sure there's gonna be a lot
of arguments about this one this is the
story of a guy who was having a mental
breakdown I guess the news that recently
came out was that he was a Subway
performer and his mental health
collapsed after his uh I think his mom
was killed is what they're reporting and
after that he kind of just lost it and
then he had been arrested 40 times he
had lunch once uh punched a 67 year old
woman in the face and so as he was
belligerent and on the subway reportedly
threatening people saying that he would
take it he was ready to die and he would
hurt people this is when the three men
subdued him the uh reportedly the Marine
told everyone to call 9-1-1 and uh get
the police down there and then he ended
up dying which has resulted in the left
like AOC whether or not people because I
don't know I don't know if you consider
her left but AOC yeah she's Progressive
she said this as a public murder
and now you've got protesters calling
for this guy to be arrested they're
saying he committed a murder and uh I
think this is actually a really good
example of what what is described as
anarcho tyranny in that you had 25
people pushed onto subway tracks in the
past year you've had uh like a woman get
raped on a train in Philadelphia and we
don't hear a single Pete from any of
these politicians from any of these
activists until someone actually stops
the guy if you go back seven kills him
right
he killed him sure yeah so so when
someone is being violent and then
someone else acts in self-defense of
others and the person dies in the
process now there's all of a sudden
calls for okay so this this guy should
be criminally charged but there was no
call for stopping the 25 people being
pushed on the subway tracks that that
that's an ongoing and acceptable thing I
suppose I'm never going to sit here and
try and defend people pushing people on
the subway tracks that's a crime like
that's terrible a type of murder yeah
exactly especially if they die so that's
horrible no one's going to be on the
other side of that argument but in terms
of like the guy who just got killed
isn't and you can correct me if I'm
wrong in this doesn't in self-defense
the poor like the proportionality of
what you're doing has to be in response
to the actual aggressive actions of the
person right it has to be proportional
is that correct so you feel in your mind
that I was a proportional response for
him to choke him out to death in that
situation because he was going to become
such a threat to the person but you you
stepped you made a big leap right there
which what's the lead you're ascribing
intent to the Marine to kill oh I'm not
saying they intended to kill on I never
said that but he did end up killing him
right so
well no but what is you're making what
has to be material Tim has to be
functionality argument or are you making
yes I'm asking you that because is what
is he proportional proportional to the
threat so the threat that he was going
it is proportional to subdue someone
that is threatening other people and
saying he'll die in the process and and
end up killing him even if that was you
so see see now you're doing it again
you're ascribing Intent no I'm not a
scrubbing intent I'm seeing the results
this is what happened the guy's dead
he's dead right material to the
proportionality of action so the
proportionality of action in your mind
was justified to what he was doing his
actual actions he held the guy on the
ground well I said killed him until he
died you're doing it again no you keep
saying I'm doing it again I'm saying
this is the end results I'm not saying
this is what he meant to do maybe he
didn't I don't know I don't know what's
in his heart either to you none of us
absolutely if someone is threatening
other people you are allowed to subdue
them and then would it be like an
involved manslaughter
but this is what happened it's to the
point of death so you have that's
criminal I'm not saying did to kill him
that's the difference right but if he
ended up dying as a result of that was
that proportional yes he he needed to be
killed no or he could have killed
someone hold on stop that you can't you
keep trying to say needed to be no no
that's what happened that's the end
result you're saying the Marine tried to
kill him no I didn't say that then why
don't you say that why would you put
words in my mouth I'm saying that's what
ended up happening
needed to be killed because what he did
to him his choke out ended up with a guy
dying so that was the end result so his
proportional response to what he thought
was a threat was that I'm gonna choke
him out I'm not trying to kill him but
I'm going to choke him out whether or
not he dies is going to be something
that we're just going to remain to be on
the cards right this is chance we'll
leave it at the chance so you are making
a huge leap right there there's no way
Tim yeah what he's doing is that
proportional is choking someone with the
possibility of death show with the
possibility of death yes okay so that's
okay let's just say this let me tell you
so if uh someone tried illegally
entering my home sure I will use
whatever Force necessary to stop them
from illegal entering my home and
illegally entering my home right I have
the the legal justification in the state
that I live in to use whatever Force
necessary to stop someone from entering
my home illegally now you can't invite
someone in and there's actually some
some legal barriers here like if someone
actually walks up to your house and the
door is open and they walk in that's
actually not an illegal entry it is to a
certain degree but it's like trespass
it's like your door was open there was
no obstruction and then you'll make an
argument about entering the domicile
could be considered fourth degree
burglary depending on which state you're
in if they actually open the door and
enter they've now committed felony
burglary and you are entitled in West
Virginia to use whatever Force necessary
to stop someone from illegally entering
your house that doesn't mean you just
intend to actually kill someone so in
terms of we're out in the street someone
is threatening someone else you are
legally entitled to subdue them now even
if that sub like even in the act of
doing that you could kill them yes
absolutely absolutely because uh where
you're going with it is like what what
what sub what what act of subduing would
be permitted in your mind then like
holding his hands tightly uh one that
doesn't have a possibility of death I
would say because if it's give me one
and you're and you're in your uh and
your Martial Arts expertise
um zero absolutely okay yeah so there's
nothing and I think I can contend that
no one here has any right all right am I
in a Junior I've just watched a lot of
movies
no but uh sharp elbows but but no none
of us have black belts we don't know
this we're just people who talk on
the internet going black vessel I mean I
have hostile environment training and I
have some minimal martial arts strength
minimal minimal minimal I didn't I've
done uh I've done some Kung Fu Taekwondo
so once again there's no experts here
yeah uh so certainly we'll contend I am
not an expert however
if someone is threatening harm against
another person and three people find it
reasonable to subdue him and the person
dies that person was in the process of
committing a crime if you lose your life
in the process of committing a crime I'm
not going to blame the victims for this
right would you blame the victims for
this when you're saying victims you mean
the people who killed them the people
who are being attacked but were they
attacked prior or did they try to subdue
him so do we have do we have footage
before so in New York for example if you
go up to someone and threaten them
you've committed a crime right you've
committed a criminal act of violence
against another person by threatening
them and going up to their face
right and so you're saying at that point
you have the ability to proportionately
respond with so violence yeah actually
there's a there's a video of this uh
myth informed has it seven years ago
this man was called a hero for defusing
Violence by putting another man in a
Chokehold a man in the subway was
getting up in people's faces and he was
threatening them and another man got it
behind him and put him in a Chokehold
and he was put on national television
and he was celebrated as a hero for
doing so so this is what I'm talking
about anarcho tyranny I feel like you're
latching onto this completely from a
point of uh you don't have knowledge on
proper uh technique for subduing an
individual no none of us do no the legal
expertise
but see see that that's kind of an
absurd thing to just outright well well
look I'm gonna say this guy committed a
murder and should go to prison but I'm
not an expert in neither are you
therefore he should I never said that
I'm actually asking questions because
these are things that I don't fully
understand about is it legal for him to
do what he did is it is illegal yes okay
that's why he wasn't charged he was
released however in this day and age
what's likely going to happen is anarcho
tyranny people go out in the streets
they protest and the police say for
political reasons we're going to go find
this guy and we're going to arrest him
but I don't know it depends
unfortunately we don't have footage of
what happened before the show that's
what I'd like to know but if there's
enough people on the train that are are
witness to what was happening and
they're like yo he was threatening all
of us are not going to mess with that
and that's what was reported and there
were three men trying to subdue him as
he fought back so there's there's like
there's there's no debate that this guy
was acting violently and threatening
people and even said he was prepared to
die at that point you have what what
could be a terroristic threat I think I
think if a guy got in a train and
screamed I'm going to cause harm to
people and then said he was willing to
die you'd probably want to stop him
because there's signs all over the
subway saying if you see something say
something and I suppose we could go the
route of uh when when lucrutkowski had
that video there was a guy in a Subway
with a knife stabbing people and the cop
said we're not going to get involved at
all and then some guy had to try and
intervene himself it's funny that guy's
a hero yeah that was I think oh yeah
here it is Matt Walsh retweeted
Alexandra Cortez's tweet from six hours
ago and asking specifically what are
they supposed to do what are people
supposed to do in this situation are
they supposed to sit there if someone's
screaming they're gonna they're gonna
hurt somebody you just sit there and
wait until they actually hurt the person
and then you respond and I'm just I'm
just curious you know honest question uh
we have the story from the daily mail
from October 25 victims have been shoved
in front of subway cars so far this year
uh two victims were killed where where
was the protest
well you know where was the video
footage of it there's video there is
video footage of it is it public yes
public video footage and I'm not gonna I
can't play it on YouTube but yo there's
video footage of people being pushed in
front of trains and and and where's AOC
where's any of these protesters
nowhere to be found in arcot tyranny is
that when the criminals do it as
explained in uh was it sultanitsen the
the gulag archipelago when a criminal
does this act in the Soviet Union they
didn't that's just a criminal that's
what they do but when you the citizen
defend yourself you knew better but so
you're blaming EOC for not bringing
attention to this specifically so is it
meaning or are you saying that she she's
she's hypocritical because she doesn't
talk about the people being pushed in
front of trains but she's talking about
this now I'm not saying hypocritical no
I'm saying I have a question of why why
now why only when people are victimized
and they defend themselves are they are
we now upset about what happened
victimized we're talking about a poor
homeless person who attacks may have
been having uh an episode and died in
what like ended up being the struggle
that's so why are the people who were
subduing him victims what what makes
these victims he assaulted them so you
have that on camera that he assaulted
them first according to all the news
reports and the police and the witness
statements can we see the footage I want
to see I haven't seen that yet I think
we can show the choke out okay so
according to the news reports the
witnesses and the police he went and
threatened violence against people which
is assault right would you see any
specifically threatened violence against
the people who subdued him do we have
evidence of that it's one thing for him
to be in a train being like I'm I'm not
winning an argument here I'm not trying
to win an argument I'm actually pedantic
awfully pedantic yes why would you use
pedantic in this in this form as in like
I'm trying to get to the root of this
problem no no it's absurd to imply that
if a woman if a guy walks up to a woman
and says he's going to harm her that
another man can't protect right and so
this is why I'm asking did he say to the
people who subdue who subdued him I'm
going to harm you yes I'm going to hurt
you that's immaterial to a self-defense
claim and proportionality okay if this
guy was threatening people right and
then someone said I'm going to stop you
before you hurt someone that is legal
self-defense acting in the defense of
others that makes those people who who
are stopping the guy threatening people
the victims of a violent individual who
is trying to cause harm
yeah I just find it fascinating that
there's a there's an effort to defend
the aggressor in this circumstance right
oh so you're suggesting that the guys
even if the guys that were choking out
weren't the ones being threatened that
they're still considered a victim
because they stepped in to defend other
people well I'm saying outright that if
you're on a train and there's a guy
you're on a train you can't get off that
train you are you are trapped yeah right
I used to live in Flatbush I used to I
used to take these trains every single
day I have seen this I've seen this and
worse I've seen people in the middle of
episodes where I was like this person
could potentially either harm themselves
or harm me it never crossed my mind that
I need to choke them out to the point of
potential death in order to protect
everyone else on the train that never
even meant to my mind so that's why I'm
asking you do you have specific footage
of him threatening the very people who
subdued and ended up killing him but why
does that matter I don't think there is
footage
well then that's all I want to know what
does that have to do with what I said
that's why I understand your your
thoughts because I would think that the
proportionality being that you ended up
killing them even if that was not your
intent I understand that you don't think
he intended to do that fine but even if
that was it were they like
threats to him in the immediate like
present where were they on the verge of
committing an act of violence towards
him that required proportional violence
that ended up in death but it's not a
requirement someone threatens you for
you to act in defense of others
right so your question is kind of in in
an unnecessary Direction and I don't
elaborate if you're on a train and
you're trapped in a box and someone is
threatening violence then yeah you're a
victim because so I've been a victim
multiple times
absolutely okay it's the craziest thing
to me I I don't feel like a victim I've
never been hurt I never was hurt by
people who are going through those kind
of videos people have been I I'm not
saying they haven't I'm not I'm not
saying there's only five people who are
pushed in front of trains okay so these
25 people were pushing from trains how
is that directly related were these
people also going through episodes were
they also people who were homeless did
they have mental illness like I I would
say shoving someone in front of a train
at random is like going through an
episode you know what I mean the
correlation is that crime and murder on
the subway has been increasing or has at
least been apparent in the Press but I
don't see you caring about it at all
until it's the aggressor who gets who
gets killed no one I think on the left
is going to defend this stat that you're
playing then why put a guy in prison for
finally saying stop killing people this
is like Tim if I approach to you today
and I was like hey do you know what goes
on in Rikers Island have any of you done
a show on what happens at Rikers Island
how they hold people in Rikers Island do
you know what we not Rikers Island
specifically but we talk about prison
reform all the time okay do you know
about bail reform and the fact that
people die in Rikers Island waiting
waiting to have their day in court
because they can't afford it and we've
talked about it and you've done entire
shows on that and you've talked about
how people literally die in prison yeah
while they're waiting for that we
talked about terrible okay so we talked
actually talked about one guy who got
wrongly arrested lost his job was kicked
out of his apartment went to Rikers for
three months only to be released and
then told sorry there's nothing you can
do about it the city owes him nothing
because they considered the prosecution
not to be malicious but this is the
problem man like
we we we talk about stuff like this all
the time but example you just gave me
was not me talking about the systemic
problem of people who are poor being in
righteousness
before they get to trial they die before
they get they're not released you just
gave me a story of someone who was
released by prior to an example of a
specific show we've actually talked
about someone wrongly held and had their
life destroyed okay now of course we can
we can we can go on further and say yes
people have died yes the system is
corrupt and my point is this when we
talk about stuff like this like wow in
October we talked about 25 people being
pushed in front of push in front of
train cars you guys just all over
us and ignore these problems then
finally when when three guys ignoring
this I told you no one's on the other
side of this no no no no it is your
protest where's your protest where's my
protest yeah where's your brother
where's your Rikers protest we headed on
the show but you did a protest you did
an actual protested
we don't go on the streets ever but I'm
not I'm not blaming you for not talking
about the Tim because this is like this
is the problem of like you are judging
someone based on absence based on your
absence of caring about something why
haven't you talked about this Lance the
fact that you haven't talked about this
means that you don't care about that
that's not that's not true though that's
not what that's the implication of what
you're saying right now my implication
is instead of helping us deal with this
when we talk about it you make up
garbage about us and then post nonsense
on the internet what if I brought up
garbage about people pushing people to
trains this is the most random talking
about you saying I'm saying you you
don't talk about it right I'm not
criticizing you for not talking about
I'm saying finally when there are people
who are like we've had 25 people push in
front of trains we've had two of them
killed I'm not gonna let this person
hurt somebody it's y'all saying that
person should go to prison
so how is that solving the problem you
guys are making it worse your protests
your support for the criminals make this
worse so our solution to this if you're
asking when you're saying you you mean
the left right our solution to a lot of
this you're speaking in support of the
criminal so I'm saying you okay so I am
saying that the solution to a lot of
this would be investing very heavily in
things like Health Care like getting and
making sure that people have access to
it and not cutting the restrictions like
allowing people to have access to health
care not as a requirement based on how
much money they have based on their
income but allowing them to get the care
they need that would have gone a long
way to preventing a problem like this
and future problems that are going to
happen I have no idea what's going on
with the 25 people been pushing front of
uh trains if it happens to be because
people have mental illness this is a
tangible solution that we could work
towards this is something that I'm are
you against that idea about investing
heavily into Mental Health Care Public
Health Care well then there there you go
so that's a much better line so here's
my issue my issue is when this story
came out in October we talked about it
and we said why is this happening what
are the solutions what are the problems
when when this story comes out now you
completely ignorant of what's been going
on in New York side with the criminal
and so people like me are flabbergasted
that we've been focused on the the the
issue of crime the issue of mental
health the entire time going back
several years because and this is why I
left in New York because of because two
cops got murdered outside of my
apartment and then what do we hear
protesters in the street defending the
criminals you keep saying criminal I
have a problem with criminalizing people
who are homeless or people who are poor
or people who are mentally ill and then
suddenly I'm not saying he's a criminal
for being poor I'm saying he's a
criminal because he threatened people
with with harm
like incitement to balances of crime
just like AOC says right I really want
to see the start of this video footage I
want to see the moment where he was
threatening the very people who tries to
take it but look either you accept that
the witnesses the media and the police
say this is what happened or we can
agree no one has any idea so there's no
point even talking about it I like I
think the interesting um maybe
Confluence is that you were mentioning
preventative measures are a way to go
about it what do you think about
defensive measures like people should be
armed and ready for this kind of thing
regardless of the prevention methods I
mean when it comes to defensive measures
and people should be armed I'm going to
probably be on the exact opposite as the
rest of you because you're probably very
pro-gun here right I'm just making yeah
we don't have the same problems in
Canada that you do in the United States
for mass shootings for Mass Gun Violence
for that kind of stuff yeah 30 million
people don't if there's a 30 million
okay so by ratio of the population Tim
so if you compare ratio of the
population Canadians to America we don't
have mass shootings like you do no one
else does it's a uniquely American
problem the mass shooting thing is a
uniquely American obesity he's pretty
heavy well well it's it's I don't think
it's fair to say uniquely American
because there are mass shootings in many
other countries oh there is but it's a
unique American problem that it's
disproportionately happening here well
mass killings aren't a uniquely American
problem but Mass killing is done with
the use of firearms is much more
uniquely American I don't think anyone's
going to debate that countries that have
fewer Firearms are going to have fewer
people killing each other with Firearms
it then becomes Australia has more per
capita than the United States
that is not true no no country comes
close to the United States list of
countries by no no okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry uh
so my basic Point yeah that was way way
off uh the United States is not the most
it is one two three four five six seven
eight ninth okay Salvador and so if all
the other countries in that list which
of them are considered part of the G20
you have to compare countries that have
similar economic systems similar
economic like uh societal uh you know
structures the United States place is
number one when you compare them to any
other G20 countries yeah no so it's true
that as far as developed Nations go the
United States does have a much higher
rate of gun violence I don't deny that
my argument is simply that other nations
do have higher rates depending on the
nation that you're looking at there's
still a pretty decently High homicide
rate and a lot of developed countries
and there are a lot of mass killings in
the United States those mass killings
are generally carried out with Firearms
but according to CDC studies Firearms
are used to prevent more violent crimes
each year than they're used to commit so
it's a much more complex argument than
simply saying the US has more firearm
deaths therefore restricting firearm
ownership would prevent those let me let
me ask you too sure do you know what
kind uh what country has the most
grenade attacks uh I only know the
answer because I saw you typing it I
think Sweden I actually didn't type that
yeah
I would have no idea murder rate was a
very clumsy I saw you typed it but yeah
I didn't type in Sweden I typed in most
grenade attacks by country and Sweden is
the only thing that comes up wow and um
yeah Sweden has more grenade attacks
than any other country but grenades are
illegal there
I would love to answer this question so
if you're going back to guns and and the
US versus Canada when I said that
there's G20 uh if we look at all the G20
countries the United States
disproportionately by ratio of the
population has way more gun deaths way
more gun violence and a lot of that gun
violence by the way is people killing
themselves just so we're completely
clear yeah but
if you look at it in the framework of
Canada has a very different set of rules
for firearms than the United States does
you can still have a firearm in Canada
you just have to take a two-day course
and you get a license and then you get
gun trading and then you have the
ability to buy guns and that way
everyone has a license they know how to
use Firearms properly they're not just
going to be running around the streets
point to them and then all that kind of
and you can also control for that
but that's not that's not what's
happening in the United States like
people just running around randomly like
no I'm not saying that it is but I'm
saying that that is in my in my opinion
that is a better system I'm not I'm I'm
not trying to take your guns away hell
no uh I think guns are fun uh we all
love shooting guns I like having a
second penis I'm just saying that like
at the end of the day if you look at how
it works with Canada this could be
applied to United States federally you
could have a program a federal program
where you have to have a two-day gun
training program you tax the gun
producers and the weapons manufacturers
and then you get them to pay for it so
poor people could afford this program
right but you can't do that because gun
ownership is a constitutional right or I
should say gun ownership is a human
right
guaranteed protected against the
government infringement um I'm all about
training in schools I think the public
schools should have gun training for
kids like they used to do gun clubs we I
would highly advocate for more training
but you're just suggesting that you
can't force it on people the
Constitution uh clearly and according to
the writings of the founding fathers and
to I think Heller versus DC uh gun
ownership is a human right and the
Constitution protects against government
infringement of that right that being
said we got the NFA we got the the the
updates the NFA in the 80s so certainly
gun rights have been infringed to an
absurd degree you know not to mention
back in the uh days when they when they
codified the Constitution people owned
warships privately and Halliburton
Northrop Grumman well I shouldn't say
Halliburton they're they're a
construction thing but Northrop Grumman
Boeing Etc these companies are private
companies that build nuclear weapons so
we basically where we're at right now is
that private corporations with no
accountability can have the most
powerful weapons of mass destruction in
the world
but them in the government and like so
the con like I just it doesn't follow
either the people have the power or they
don't have the power right we've
abdicated it to corrupt organizations
and corporations are not people right
let's be clear uh this this regarding
this dude to choke the guy out I think
what's going to come up is was it was it
adequate force or was it too much and I
feel like if he had punched the guides
in directly in the face that would have
been worse because although it like if
they got no fist fight because he could
have fallen backward and hit his head at
least this he was in control of the
guy's body it's it's really sad that the
guy died but I feel like this was like a
very low level amount of force to apply
to someone that was threatening to kill
people or hurt people why why why did
three people find it necessary flailing
and Kicking and Screaming you know so
it's it is hard because you mentioned
there's no footage prior but something
happened that resulted in three New York
people who are likely not conservatives
to decide this man must be subdued yeah
three people so so when it comes to the
idea of proportionality I'm like if
three New Yorkers of all people were
like this guy's got to be stopped that's
kind of crazy to me because look I'm I'm
I'm I'm a gun nut right you my my view
is people have a right to defend
themselves with a lot more Force than
people in New York do but if people in
New York felt they had to stop him these
people you know I thought these guys are
conservative there's like no
conservatives living here it's like 20
Republican and if they are Republican
they're probably moderate right
something must have happened but that
but I don't even need to sit here and
say what could have or what must have
what we know what we choose to believe
based on what the police the media and
the witnesses have said is that this guy
was threatening people with violence and
said he was prepared to lose his life
over it three three men then said this
man must be subdued and they subdued him
and then the guy died which sucks it's
unfortunate they did get a cause of
death it was a compression of the neck
yeah so you've got a massive platform
here a lot of people watch you all the
time and so what you say Obviously an
advocate for is going to affect a lot of
people's lives if this is a problem that
genuinely concerns you why isn't it
something that you would frame and want
to advocate for more resources for
mental health access and and bring that
up on a regular basis and I'm not saying
I'm sure I'm not okay hold on Tim I'm
sure you've done it before I'm sure
you've had specials before I'm what we
do it a lot okay why isn't that the
focus why isn't why isn't today hey by
the way everybody this horrifying
tragedy happened on the New York subway
we got to talk about this yeah here's
here's our angle our angle is we need to
invest in mental health we need to
invest in giving access to public health
care for Americans first of all uh
when it comes to the issue of violence
in this country conservatives have been
screaming about mental health for
decades Reagan is one of the ones that
like gutted the institutions in America
yeah Reagan's one of the worst
Presidents this country has ever had no
fault divorce how about that yeah
uncontrolled yeah hula I don't know why
Republicans like that guy they're
they're the reason that they like him is
because of the way that he stood up to
Communism but I totally agree that he
had a lot of really bad policies but
conservatives have taken the stance of
gun violence and mass shootings an issue
of mental health and then the left takes
the the opposing but do they invest in
that do they vote for it because
Republican party is garbage when I look
up the votes of the Republican Party
they're not voting for amendments that
are actually going to like give people
more access to mental health but but
that's that's where you have but that's
where you have an opportunity but you
don't want to come on to a show where we
say the Democratic and Republican party
should be dismantled and obliterated and
then make an argument that one side is
bad I'll sit here and be like bro if you
want to have a a make a list of every
single member of Congress who should be
removed from office I will put all of
them but like four one problem is that
when people advocate for mental health a
lot of that application is more drugs
that this new drug will fix your brain
but I'm of the belief that less drugs
allow you to fix your like sometimes for
very short periods of time you might
need something to help but then you
don't want people long term I don't want
them on psycho you know crazy
Pharmaceuticals that make them go you
know right right and and we have to
bring up uh often this medication
actually increases suicidal ideation and
aggressive thoughts and things like that
but I do want to answer your question
you said why isn't that the subject of
like the show today or the premise or
the framing right because when we do
talk about this stuff on like a normal
day when news breaks of like 25 people
push in front of trains sure or a woman
was raped on a train in Philadelphia and
we're sitting here saying like what is
going on in these cities what are the
failed policies that are resulting in
this we talk about it all the time today
we're talking about the fact that
protesters went out in New York and
physically assaulted one of our friends
and reporter because he simply filmed
them and they are demand in criminal
charges of the guy who tried to stop the
violent offense see that is a
narco-tyranny that when you have ongoing
crime when you have victimization people
being killed and a woman being raped on
a train we we talked for a year two
years three years when the when the
riots happen in 2020 we had Michael
Tracy's reporting showing all the rides
across the country and the mom and pop
shops are putting up signs saying please
don't hurt us we talk about it Non-Stop
and then one day someone on a train
three guys say we must stop this man
maybe because they were like we've seen
too many people die on these train
tracks before and now we've got leftist
protesters saying that guy should go to
prison for it and AOC calling it a
public murder I'm like yo AOC I didn't
see you call out the public murder in
the subway trains and again maybe it's
ignorance but the problem I see is this
is why I refer to the left as NPCs or a
cult there is complete ignorance to the
problem ongoing and then a hyper
polarization in a single moment in the
wrong direction which makes the problem
worse you know what's so wild is the
other side feels the exact same way
except we're not conserving these
exactly you see that's the problem okay
is it all right if I jump in with
something right because
he's a moon Lord I've also I've been
reluctant to interject because I don't
want to just dog pile and so I didn't
want to get in on it
I promise
no I'm here for the dog pound so
I think when you talk about mental
health in trying to solve the problem of
mental health in this country that is a
deceptively simple way of putting it
right every single person in this room
would have a very different idea of how
that problem should be solved and I
agree with you that right now
Republicans aren't doing a whole lot to
talk about mental health issues
at least with respect to whatever's New
York you know mental health issue that
this specific person is dealing with but
never because it's not a republican
place no no I I totally agree with that
too but I'm saying he was saying why
don't Republicans do more to advocate
for mental health treatment my point
however is that I think the kind of
advocacy you'd see from conservatives on
how to solve the problem of bad mental
health in the United States would be a
much different set of policy
prescriptions than you would want
so so one example of this actually what
Ian said and so what Ian said so and
there's a number of different directions
you could take this in my fundamental
belief is that we live in a culture that
encourages man to live in ways that man
is not meant to live and you just see
negative Health outcomes from that both
mental and physical however when you
look at traditional psychological
definitions of mental illness and how we
used to treat it back in the 1950s you
had about 500 000 people in the United
States in insane asylums by the 1980s
it's about a hundred thousand okay so
without even adjusting for the increase
in population size there's a
significantly lower number of people who
are committed and part of that is
because the requirement to get somebody
committed involuntarily to a mental
health facility at that time was they
can't take care of themselves today they
have to demonstrate that they are a
danger to themselves and others first
before they can be committed now is
someone not being able to take care of
themselves necessarily the perfect
indicator of whether they need to be
committed to one of these institutions I
have no idea however what I do know is
once we push the goal post all the way
in the other direction and say they have
to demonstrate that that they are a
significant danger to themselves or
others oftentimes they don't get
committed until after they've already
hurt somebody so it's a much more
complicated situation than saying we
just have to throw more money at this
system when we don't even have a solid
definition of what good mental health is
and also at which point someone should
be committed so I think I think the the
the the important Point going back to
what I I agree uh this is not a
conservative show
but if you are in a cult you wouldn't
know that you would you would only hear
what the cult says so so here's here's
what I have to respond to that if if an
objective person say an alien just
showed up and looked at your channel Tim
and went through all the videos and you
were to ask them pull them is this
person and his views where would you
place them most likely they would say
conservative that's that's good actually
yes but more because the guests that
come on don't just look at the guests
but the way they're framed the
thumbnails the the words that you put in
red and the you know whether or not
you're supporting or going against one
either the Democrats or Republicans but
hey you you tell me that you guys don't
like the Democrats and you don't like
the Republicans it's not a republican
stream you don't want to endorse
Republicans in any way shape or form or
vote for them
okay sure but there's a lot of
right-wingers who watch you right so you
that's what I mean when I say you do
have a voice and you do have an audience
of right Wingers who are going to vote
for another 30 of your audiences most of
the people who watch this the largest
faction is libertarian okay the next
largest is would be considered
traditional Liberal oh no no I think the
uh but along party lines who are the
Libertarians going to vote for not the
libertarian party most likely they're
going to vote for whoever on this show
and say abolish the police one of the
two Republican yeah most likely yes one
of the two so that's why I say Tim for
the people who watch you who are
Republican leaning why not frame it that
way for them so that they can actually
start pushing more money into that
that's why I'm here uh that's basically
true I think that's what moon Lord does
so here's here's what I think I think
you're an occult right okay I I think
the cult is derived from algorithms on
social media okay so you only surround
yourself with this loud noise we saw a
really good example of this with that
assistant guy is that his name Harry
Harry Sisson yeah those two guys went on
the Tim Dillon podcast and he said
please no no don't clip this I will lose
followers I can rag on Trump all the
time and like people still watch the
show uh Sheamus and I can have an
argument over me being pro-choice and
him being pro-life and people still
watch the show and if I pull up all
sides with 3770 ratings Tim pool is a
Centrist but you think I'm conservative
because you live in a bubble right so
I'm too far left the opportunity it goes
too far away yes so like when I go hang
out in Washington DC right and I do I go
to National Harbor or I go to Baltimore
Maryland I'm in Baltimore I don't know
why you do that Washington DC the people
who come up to me and are like hey man
I'm a big fan are not conservatives they
hate Donald Trump in fact I was at a
poker table last week and a guy said I
just hate Donald Trump man I can't stand
them I wish somebody else would run but
I can't vote for Joe Biden
you I I think you're surrounded this we
talk about this quite a bit sure if if
all sides has nearly 4 000 uh people
rating me and the end result is Centrist
if I'm actively pro-universal Healthcare
not to the same degree as like Bernie
Sanders I believe in Private health
insurance and I'm pro-choice
I am absolutely not a conservative in
this country I've listened to your
debates on pro-choice so your pro-choice
from a Temple's perspective I'm a choice
from a traditional liberal perspective
as it's not from what people who would
Define themselves as pro-choice would
say right like you concentrate very
heavily on the ninth month abortions and
baby Guillotines and stuff like that
like yeah yeah I remember watching
debate Guillotine yeah okay so baby
Guillotines is my own personal
interpretation and joke of it but you
were talking about how women uh how how
like disgusted you are that women may
have an abortion in the ninth month
right or or even a viable baby of a
viable baby and I I wanted to scream at
that time being like women who have
abortions in the ninth month they're not
doing that because they got bored or all
of a sudden they're like oh I don't care
anymore they do that because it's a
tragedy like statistically women
who are getting abortions in the ninth
month is because there's a medical
complication that could kill them that's
why they have to do it
real world I already said viable I'll
try again what are you talking about Tim
I already said abortion a viable fetuses
ridiculous you know do you know viable
means yes yes it means the baby can
survive without another complicated
absolutely and why the liberalized
abortion of viable fetuses at nine
months when the baby could just women
are not getting abortions at the ninth
month for pleasure or because they want
to suddenly do it for kicks no that
doesn't happen it's a tragedy
because there are medical operations
that could kill the mother and they need
to get an abortion why legalize I just
told you that's the reason why so all
right I'll try and break it down for you
if can the baby survive okay let's let's
talk about a baby the baby can survive
on its own yes sure okay abortion is
defined by Planned Parenthood and the
law as terminating the life of the of
the baby correct why terminate the life
of the baby if it can survive on its own
because it could kill both of them
that's why it is done at that stage so
how to kill one or the other and they
have to make the tough decision at that
point so how do you remove the fully
formed month baby at that point oh I I
don't know the signs of it I I've never
before that operation so shouldn't the
law then be
if the baby must be removed and it is
alive and capable of survival all
actions must be taken to preserve the
life of the child and the mother I would
say they'd probably choose the mother
first right why and and then this is
such a strange scenario how often do you
think that this happens and all of a
sudden they're like the baby could have
lived you could have done it why did you
choose the other option it's like this
is a tragedy of the highest order
because they want to have the kid at
nine months pregnant a woman is on her
way to give birth so it's like it's the
worst possible time that's not
always again I said I didn't want a dog
pile but that's the I mean that's it's
statistically not true there have been
surveys done on women who had later
abortions and for a a pretty large sum
of them it's because they were not sure
whether the father of the child was
willing to commit and then when they
found out he wasn't willing to commit
they would have the abortion uh and so
there are different stats you're going
to find for different points in
pregnancy when it comes all the way
along to nine months I don't have the
statistical uh data on that however I do
know for later term abortions there are
reasons other than what is traditionally
considered to be a medically necessary
reason for example some people will say
that um
a negative mental health outcome is a
reason to abort a child later in
pregnancy so if the woman is depressed
they will list that as a reason for why
the child had to be terminated to save
the life of the mother which is
certainly not the case very obviously
and to the point of what Tim is saying
when we say there's no such thing as a
medically necessary abortion the
principle behind that is if there is an
operation which is necessary to save the
life of the mother and then she
miscarries the child as a result of that
operation which was necessary to save
her life that's not an abortion because
nobody's intent was to go in there and
end the life of The Unborn Child and so
if a woman's having complications where
she has to deliver early you deliver the
child early of course and if you're at a
point in pregnancy where the child isn't
viable that's a horrible tragedy you
still do what you can to save the child
but you can't always save the child and
we understand that but to go in and rip
the Child Apart to end their life is
never something which is medically
required even though an early delivery
maybe but what are there situations
where if the baby is in this is so harsh
uh in its complete form that even trying
to induce early pregnancy could kill the
mother so they have to break the baby's
body apart so that they can get it out
without killing the mother I've never
heard of such a thing so and there are
there are Letters by the way son signed
by literally thousands of doctors
so 88 of abortions are in the first 12
weeks 88 88 of abortions less than 1.3
percent of abortions take place near the
eighth or ninth month how many is that
good marker well how many is that I
don't know the actual numbers 13 000.
okay but we're talking about less than
one point three percent hold on 13 000
that's the number of people who die from
gun violence in the US each year that
aren't suicide
to justify abortion when it happens as
well
there is 338 million Americans I'm sorry
the numbers are going to be a little
daunting yes the numbers will be high
I'm not here to celebrate that I don't
understand your argument then my
argument is a thousand people die from
Guns we have a problem right
if 13 000 people die from Pennsylvania
yes of course 13 000 late term abortions
happen is that a problem these are
completely different things well how so
okay so if someone dies by got a big
shot where they killed it they killed
themselves was it a suicide was it a
good violence thing who knows
yes but in the case of late term
abortions more often than not when
statistics say and they when they are
pulled they say the reason that they are
giving it is because it's a medical
complication that could result in a
death so so let's uh I should can we
make the argument then that um
the use of guns on people are allowed
the use of Guns of people and their
lives is allowed
you're describing murder
so if Colorado for instance passes a law
saying there is no medical requirement
for an abortion
is it is it wrong to to kill the baby
you're talking about you're trying to
compare murdering someone with a gun to
a woman having to make a medical
decision that could basically preserve
her life not not a medical reason that's
what that's what I'm saying should she
have the ability to have an abortion for
any reason yes at nine months at nine
months
I would say at nine months because it
only happens according to the stats
based on uh complete medical necessity
she has a right to do it
Colorado legalized abortion in up to
nine months with no medical reason
required
do you agree I agree with that decision
yeah so so the baby could survive on its
own and the mother is legally now
allowed to just end its life she has the
right if she wanted to you're saying so
in Colorado and I'm not your question I
know I know but but I'm asking but I'm
asking you because you're the one who
brought this up I don't know what
Colorado specific law says so if you
were saying that in Colorado women have
the ability at nine months to get to
have an abortion for any reason they
could just decide yeah okay I think they
should have the right to do that but the
stats show that they're not doing that
but they should have a legal right to do
that yes it's their body it's their
choice of course so this is what I do I
disagree on I think if the baby needs to
be removed from the woman there's no
reason to kill it you know what I mean
like you could just C-section and then
put up for adoption I'm telling you that
doesn't happen but it does but but even
but but like you might be able to bring
up anecdotes but the stats don't I did
say that hold on hold on hold on hold on
like why allow it to happen I just don't
understand are are you arguing what's
going on are you arguing you oppose it
and you think it's morally wrong but you
think it should be legal I I think that
women should have the right to decide
what they do and have bodily autonomy
over their own body we're not talking
about her body we're talking it is her
body we're talking about nine months
even if it's still inside it's still her
body even if it's a viable we're talking
about the removal of the baby yes the
forceful removal of the baby or forceful
so she chooses to have that she's the
woman says the baby must be removed from
my body why kill the baby if they're
removing it I don't think they should do
that I would I would if they ask me if
they ask me lenses should I do this I
would say no but she should have a right
yes of course it's her body still no
that doesn't stop so like the woman is
pregnant the baby is viable and capable
of surviving on its own sure and she
says before it hits before it breaches
oxygen kill it do you think that should
be allowed this is again the baby
Guillotines this is why I brought that
up but but what a weird scenario this
doesn't happen this is not the real
world but it does and if the argument is
that doesn't happen enough for you to
care that's fine you're allowed to
believe that sure what I don't
understand is it seems like you your
position is a rather shock position
where you recognize there is something
in here wrong with taking the life of a
baby that could survive on its own but
you also but you're also taking the
tribal position of women should be
allowed to do it anyway no no if you
were to ask me Tim hey Lance do you
think it's a good idea of this woman
who's nine months pregnant suddenly she
got bored with the pregnancy she doesn't
have it anymore but the baby's viable do
you think that's a good thing to do I
would be like no of course then I should
be allowed because it's still her right
it's still her body but bodily autonomy
doesn't stop it my morality it's not my
choice it's not my yes but that's not my
choice
that's her choice not mine why kill the
baby ask her so ask her okay so my point
is simply this you don't need to be
shocked by it you're allowed to have
that moral position I think most people
in America would prescribe that to be uh
would ascribe evil to that that's the
idea are you guys evils whatever you
want that's up to you that's your choice
the idea that you would say doesn't mean
that she's the woman who wants the baby
removed and then in the process instead
of letting the baby live remove it but
kill it right there's no reason to do
that there's no you can give the baby up
for adoption you can drop the baby off
on the doorsup of a post office I agree
with you why legalize even if it's one
one why legalize you see this is the
crazy because her autonomy should not be
cut off based on your morality because
you don't think that idea is good you
don't like it the babies
well that's that's if it was removed
from your body and it was still viable
right and that's where the baby
Guillotine is coming because I don't
think this happens I don't think women
on the ninth month get abortions with
viable living children and then be like
I don't want to kill it I don't think
that happens you I mean you don't have
to think it happens but statistically it
does because your entire argument is
this only happens for reasons of the
health of the mother or the health of
the I don't know I said so it showed
that at the ninth month if a woman is
going to have an abortion it's typically
because it's a medical complication that
could either endanger her or the child's
life and what I'm saying is there are
doctors who will justify that by saying
the medical complication is she is
depressed that is literally one of those
okay okay but Sheamus I got to stop you
because this is a nebulous argument that
doesn't get anywhere and and I can
respect the point that uh if if you go
to a left if you try and look this up
you're gonna find left-wing uh uh
sources and right-wing sources that will
contradict each other so my question is
strictly on the legality of terminating
the life of a child we we I can sit here
and pull up oh hey here's one women uh
abort Down syndrome babies late term
rather frequently I think that's wrong I
don't think that someone's life is
forfeit because they have Down syndrome
but your argument is that they do I know
it's not that that's a strong no no no
your argument is that women have a right
to terminate a baby for any reason at
any point yes they should have the
bodily autonomy to make that decision so
what I'm saying is in the circumstance
of down syndrome I think it is wrong to
terminate a baby's life at nine months
simply for having Down syndrome but you
would agree she is legally allowed to do
so I I think she should be legally
allowed to do so whether or not I think
that's a good idea Israel then there's
the clarification I think it should be
okay I don't I think so there are limits
to how much bodily autonomy women should
have so yes right uh so okay so that's
your sense the pro-choice argument
because you're pro-abortion right
pro-choice traditionally in this country
put limits at around like 15 to 16 weeks
meaning if the baby is dependent upon
the body of the mother then it is the
body of the mother and she has final say
if the baby is viable it can be removed
in in a process that ends the pregnancy
but doesn't end the life of the baby
that's kind of like the compromise where
the baby gets to live and the woman no
longer has to be pregnant there seems to
be this
amoral argument where but it just killed
the baby anyway which doesn't make any
logical sense that's the pro-abortion
side so if you go back to the 90s if you
go back to Safe legal rare Etc if you
even look at Tulsi gabbard in 2020
that's where I'm at conservatives are
pro-life outright Jamis would argue
abortion in any capacity should be
banned entirely
I'm in the traditional Democrat position
but you see there is a tribal amoral a
logical position of just let them kill
the baby regardless I don't I don't see
any logic there I don't see how that
makes sense morally or ethically or or
just mathematically right so you said
I'm pro-abortion what I'm against is
forced birth and I don't think the state
should be forcing women to give birth
against their will which is what your
position and your position is so so I'm
against that
government I don't think they
should be forcing them and turning
completely agree viable wounds I
completely agree I'm against forced
birth just like you except my difference
is that if the baby's at eight months
and can survive they can take the baby
out as if they would have an abortion
but not kill it in the process if it's
available at eight months is it viable
yes it is yes it is dude there have been
babies after 20 weeks position is that
women have a right to kill the baby even
if they end the pregnancy and there's no
logic there the logic is that I don't
think you you agree with forced birth at
a point how at eight months at eight
months Tim Poole thinks Force birth is
cool
a woman could end her pregnancy whenever
she wants say it Tim Poole said a woman
can end her pregnancy whenever she wants
yeah
make up something fake Tim Paul agrees
with Force birth is a false statement
you're lying I have already said I
believe that women have a right to
terminate their pregnancy after a
certain amount of time
yes the baby is viable that she
shouldn't have the right to be able to
terminate it to kill the baby yes I said
she can end the pregnancy whenever she
wants and in the pregnancy can be giving
birth or a boarding or a C-section that
keeps the business she has to be forced
to give birth against her will in a
C-section but the baby is viable and
they give us so how do they remain
either way the baby comes out of her
yourself so you literally want forced
birth you literally want to force women
to give birth again
you're saying she should they should use
the the tools to rip apart the body and
pull that out whereas I'm saying they
should just take it she should have the
right to decide what happens to her body
that's it okay but I so if all right
either way the child is coming out
you're making this argument about forced
birth either way what is in her body is
going to be outside of it the question
is is it okay to shove forceps into the
skull of the small person who's inside
of her and then tear them apart limb by
limb to get them out or should we say no
that's not an acceptable way of
delivering a baby you shouldn't kill
that unborn child how is that for either
way it comes out of her body either way
the child comes out of her body it's not
as if there's one scenario
magically disappears
forced to birth is a nonsense but yeah
but in your scenario she's being forced
to give birth against her will actually
she's already pregnant dude I know but
we're not talking about
but then endorse that position I did
stick by it I know I rejected there's no
such thing I can't kill that here let me
let me tell you how fascinating this is
because she's the last baby so
legalizing the killing of a baby at nine
months that I can sit here and say I
think women should be able to terminate
their pregnancy whenever they want but
if the baby is viable the Judgment no
reason she has she has to be forced to
give it then she has to be forced to
give birth and then give the baby up is
what you're saying give birth Define yes
okay so so that is forced birth right so
so she can't decide to terminate in
eight or nine months Define give birth
you just said at eight months if the
baby is viable I'd say eight months
Define give birth I'm trying to
understand what you're saying by force
to birth what is what does birth mean
you just said when she is at eight or
nine months okay so she's at eight or
nine I said viable okay so it's viable
the baby's viable she should have to
give birth to it in some capacity
C-section whatever Define birth and I
can answer your question birth the the
removal of a child into the world from a
mother's womb if the baby so how do they
do that uh the woman pushes the baby out
so then what would you call an abortion
at eight months
is the woman pushing the baby out no
it's most likely a medical procedure
done by a doctor and what is that
medical procedure an abortion like but
what is that what is an abortion yes
like what how is it done I'm not
entirely sure that's done in eight
months I know I know earlier I know
earlier on it's usually done with a
series of rules yeah I don't know how
it's done today okay so your moral
argument is forced birth I'm trying to
understand what your position is
if you don't know how an abortion is
done then are you in favor of forced
birth am I in favor of voice no I'm
against Force birth but you think that
women should have to expel the baby
right it's completely fine for me not to
know the medical procedure of how
abortion is done to stand up for the
rights of a woman's body I don't need to
know how people perform abortions I'm
not gonna lie here I'm not going to
pretend removing a baby from a woman's
body is birth
oh so you're saying it doesn't count
of a different nature I don't think you
have a definition and I'm trying to
understand what you mean by forced birth
but if you can't define the removal of
the baby in a different way I don't know
what you're saying birth birth Tim like
the birth of a child so it's a C-section
of birth uh sure yes it is a form of
extracting the living child uh that is
viable to live in the real world that's
how you define birth extracting a living
child to live in the real world no I
would Divine birth as someone giving
birth they're pushing the baby out of
their body so so right so I don't think
women should be forced to do that right
you don't think women should be forced
to push babies out of the body but the
baby is in their body so it's got to
come out somehow so you're gonna take it
out with a C-section no I don't know but
I'm trying to figure out what you mean
by this so that would be forced birth so
he's forced to give and make a child a
viable Child live in the real
World's Gonna Come Out of you at some
point
is coming out of the woman right yes so
there's there's no there's no being in
favor of that or not it happens period
yes okay so what's your point
what's my point am I in favor of a
natural process by which a woman has to
have a baby removed from her no matter
what anyone says or does
your point is that at eight or nine
months and correct me if I'm wrong on
this Tim you are wrong yes I'll stop you
right there because because when you
keep saying eight or nine months that's
not what I said over and over and over
again my ability is after six months
you're also wrong
baby it's not six months so as soon as
the movie is viable Tim as soon as the
baby is viable then it's okay for the
woman even if she doesn't want to have
it anymore for whatever reason she
should have to be forced to have it
extracted from her and and then live is
that correct is that your position well
it's not forcing the woman to have a
baby live if the baby's already alive
you see what I'm saying like right okay
I got semantics I gotta compromise for
it I gotta compromise for you we'll tell
the mother we killed it but we'll sneak
it off and give it to someone else does
that work for you no because I still
think she should have autonomy she
should have the right to do it if she
wants to of course she should kill the
baby yeah she's already born I don't
want her to kill a baby I'm saying it
because I want her to have the ability
to choose that's different and that is a
fundamental part of this the baby these
out of her body right forcibly of course
of course let's say 24 weeks don't go to
the doctor and says I want this baby out
of me what did she says I don't want to
have this baby I don't I don't want to
have this baby okay okay and the doctor
says I will remove it okay uh oh the
baby's alive what do we do so you forced
her to give birth no no no she said
Doctor I'd like an abortion he says you
got it he's lying to her no no he does
the abortion and it fails an abortion is
terminating in pregnancy so there's no
there's no such thing as a trick
abortion they're called failed abortions
so when they perform the abortion as
Sheamus explained they stick metal tools
into the brain and scramble it up and
rip its body parts apart okay and then
pull it out chunk by chunk okay when the
babies are smaller sometimes they pull
them out but the babies don't die they
survive right so my question is in the
instance of a failed abortion what
should be done
a failed abortion being that the the
child is living it's outside of the
mother yeah at that point you cannot
kill that child that would be murder oh
okay agreed on that point right yeah so
then where does the mother's Choice come
in before before that procedure takes
place so she she has a choice to choose
what she wants to have done with her
body if if she goes to a doctor and the
doctor is like I'm going to perform an
abortion which the assumption would be
that I'm about to terminate the child
but then he just secretly sneaks the
child out of there that's not performing
an abortion you're just
being deceptive yeah and the doctor
would should go to prison if they did
something like that in my opinion you go
to prison if you should go to prison if
he performs an abortion snap yeah I
heard that opposite perspective so
there's also something that none of us
know because I don't think any of us are
medical doctors the the difference on
the physiology of the female body uh
giving a nine-month abortion having that
happen or the actual birthing process
whether by C-section or natural birth uh
it might have vastly different
consequences on the female body so
that's something to take into oh so so
wait wait remember the born alive act
yes that was a republican position
wasn't it what was it what was that yeah
so there have been a couple of different
born alive acts in different years but
what they basically say is that if the
abortion fails it is not legal to kill
the child
wasn't wasn't that Republicans were
trying to pass the Republicans were
trying to pass that that was one of the
only things Obama voted on in the Senate
he voted against it
Obama voted against it against what you
would be in favor of that
in favor of what the born alive act I'm
not completely familiar with it so if an
infant is born alive after an attempted
abortion it has the same protection of
Law and degree as a newborn
um yeah I would be okay with that
because at that point it's a it's a it's
a human if you're killing the person
that is alive outside of a womb then
that's murder right yeah I agree can I
ask you this is not a God that's great I
want to ask in good faith so yeah of
course you believe that the moment after
the child is outside of the birth canal
that they are now endowed with human
rights yes however when they are inside
of the mother literally anything you do
to them is acceptable because they're
inside of the mother oh no I don't think
anything is acceptable but I think the
mother should still have the choice
ultimate uh authority over what happens
to her body but there's a child inside
what about meth
uh uh like should she be allowed to do
meth yeah
uh I think if someone is doing meth
while they're pregnant that it is
completely acceptable for something like
uh
I don't know the name of the services in
the United States Child Services would
be yeah it's our body though
yeah it's her body she wants to do math
what's the big deal
uh the big deal is that it's she's
intentionally trying to kill a child
hold on there a minute yeah and I see
where we're going I don't I don't
understand what you're saying it's her
body it's her body wants to do meth
what's the problem
well first off doing meth is a legal
period doesn't matter if you're doing it
with a child without a child
methyl and diox MDMA maybe it's alcohol
wait sorry not Crystal Method Crystal
methods no not crystals hold on a second
MDMA is a kind of methodoxy
methamphetamine is uh ecstasy that's a
kind of meth there's also crystal meth
which is not legal MDMA is legal in some
places for therapy sessions I don't know
if it's legal yes very pregnant women
okay it is
possession oh you're right
okay dude so like sorry decentralizing
possession is different than legalizing
Crystal methods you know you know those
two things are completely different
right
um
so hold on yeah what so you so will you
decriminalize a small amount of drugs
that means if you're caught with that
drugs by a cop that means if you're
arrested you cannot be charged for one
gram two grams whatever that is
legalizing is no this is
decriminalization not legalization
legalization is a semantic term it
doesn't mean anything yes it means it
means that there's no longer a
Prohibition on that product okay so if a
woman does meth she's legally allowed to
have it right is she legally allowed to
do it or possess it I mean what's the
difference well two very different
things you can be legally allowed to
possess drugs and not be legally allowed
to take drugs for example alcohol
so she does alcohol can a woman chug a
fifth of vodka while pregnant uh yeah
she can legally but do you think she has
a right to do so I think she has a right
to do yes she has a right to do it I
don't agree with it
okay yeah and and and heroin uh it's
illegal I I actually I don't think
heroines look I think heroin actually is
was legalized I think it's controlled
but I think that one specifically was
oxycodone and Other Drugs so
she she has a right to do it whether or
not I agree with her doing it that's
completely different I don't agree with
a woman who would have an elective
abortion at nine months I think that
that is like why the about that but
I think she has the right to do it right
but do you think it's ethical that she
like oh I don't think it's ethical no of
course not because some some things are
made legal that are unethical in my
opinion and should those be made illegal
uh I mean that's a very broad question
right no no I'm sorry personal use of
methamphetamine is allowed it's a it's a
civil citation like a traffic ticket not
a criminal citation so allowed maybe is
hyperbolic uh it is a civil citation to
be caught using uh methamphetamine in
Oregon you get a ticket for it but not
no no crime so I just looked up the born
alive act by the way it says this bill
is deliberately misleading and offensive
to pregnant people and doctors and
nurses who provide their care it is
another attempt by anti-abortion
politicians to spread misinformation as
a means to get a war political end to
ban safe and legal abortion it's an
entry point to try and make abortion
illegal where did you read that okay
I don't care I mean who who cares about
the born alive act the question was if
an abortion happens but the baby
survives can you kill it and he Lance
already said no so I I we're done with
it so he would yeah yeah yeah for sure
so at any other political arguments
anyone left right or otherwise trying to
change that no no it's irrelevant once
the baby's born it's it's a baby so yeah
so it has the same rights as every other
human at that point right this is an
American this is an interesting I I
think this this Falls in line with the
idea of anarchot-tierney that we were
talking about the my view of the modern
left is that their positions are nothing
but chaos there there's there's no
logical pathway towards preserving life
uh improving people's lives it seems to
be only it's like it's like it's like
yin yang right there's one side that's
talking about long-term planning logical
thinking and improving the world on one
side that takes the inverse position no
matter what for instance 25 people push
in front of a subway nobody bats an eye
one guy three guys try to subdue a man
and now they want prison that's like a
weird inversion of what the law is
supposed to do the law should stop the
people who are pushing people on the
trains and protect the people on the
train who are being victimized but the
left's position is the inverse of it
right
are all chaos I mean if you really
wanted to boil down what the left is
fighting for especially myself it's
expanding freedom I I believe in Freedom
I love freedom I'm sure everyone here
likes Freedom too right here how do you
define Freedom exactly so for me I I
believe in a democratic process where we
don't have tyrants we don't have
dictators we don't have Kings or Queens
we have the ability as a democracy to be
able to vote for who we work for or
sorry who who our leaders are right like
we want to be able to vote for our
president our prime minister I I believe
in that fundamentally but my other thing
is I want to expand that freedom into
the workplace because we spend about
eight hours a day every single day in
our works our jobs I want to expand
Freedom there so people who work at
their jobs for eight hours a day have
the ability to vote for things in their
lives Better Health Care better working
conditions whether or not their boss is
corrupt and stealing from all of them I
want to expand that I want to expand
Freedom into other parts of life that's
that's a fundamental belief what do you
mean by stealing from them uh stealing
wages for example like actually shorting
someone's check and so so the largest
form of theft in America right now is
wage theft if you had to happen to me I
sued I I went to the National Labor
Board and we won how does it happen as
you should so there's a ton of words
paying over time not paying overtime uh
bosses uh simply just garnishing checks
or garnishing wages stealing tips or
thinking that tips for justification to
pay them lower salaries and stuff like
that yeah all of it and when
you look at theft every single like you
look at the stats right cars being
stolen jewelry all that wage theft blows
everything out like they're not even
comparable it's one down here and then
it's like the other one's all
the way up there I got sorry for you so
uh I worked at a company I get a
paycheck I'm good at math and stuff and
so I look at it and I'm like hey there's
a problem with my paycheck and they go
no it's good I'm like no it isn't
there's a problem with my paycheck fix
it and I I very quickly it was like 67
missing I want it fixed and I want to
fix now and they went uh give us a few
minutes came back 15 minutes later
handed me a check I looked at it and
said are you joking
and they were like huh and I was like
this is wrong I'm not an idiot fix my
paycheck
went to a couple other employees they
said I said let me see your paychecks I
looked and I went come with me walked
right to the National Labor Board in
Chicago and said this is what they did
they took our statements we went to the
company and we told them we were going
to form a union because of what they had
done they fired us on the spot for doing
it we sued them and then uh I'll give
you air quotes and saying we won what
actually happened was after six months
of being out of work they said you can
get retropay which will be seven
thousand dollars each or we can go to
fight and then I'll give you your job
back and I'm like if they give us our
job back they're going to retaliate
against us no no that's illegal and I
was like oh come on so we won the fight
but it really means they were able to
fire us to stop us from forming a union
so what would be a good example of
expanding sorry oh no no I just want to
make the point uh I'm not I haven't seen
the stats on wage theft causing more in
losses than all other forms of theft
combined I'll just have to take your
word for that and I'm willing to grant
that for the sake of I think that this
is yeah yeah like I said I'm I'm willing
to Grant it if that is the case
and at the very least for the sake of
argument I certainly don't agree in
involuntarily democratizing all
workplaces that's probably a much longer
interesting economic discussion happy to
engage in it with you guys too and I
suspect we would all have different
views on it I don't know if you wanted
other issues or if you want to talk I
would like to talk about that Budweiser
you're going to move to Bud I do want to
talk about lgbtq
and Budweiser opens that door ladies and
gentlemen the Anheuser-Busch CEO has
finally disavowed the Dylan Mulvaney ad
in private to investors though he's not
made a public statement sales are down
26 percent they're going to be giving
out free cases of beer to Distributors
and they've vowed to spend millions of
dollars in marketing but uh the boycott
is particularly effective I would say
and there's videos now coming out of
people at sporting events where the Bud
Light is just behind the counter totally
full and everyone's buying other brands
so uh Ian and Sheamus both just leave at
the same time yeah I don't know where
they went but they ran for both leave so
uh so yeah uh let's let's jump into this
one your thoughts on the on the
Budweiser thing uh my thoughts are keep
going you're doing awesome all of you I
I mean this to every single person
protesting Bud Light yes I am so
here for this it's amazing
right on yeah yeah but but Budweiser
sucks and as a bush sucks it's a massive
multinational corporation there's super
anti-lgbtq plus so it's been beautiful
to see I love it oh they donate so much
to right-wing Republicans lgbtq laws so
Anheuser-Busch getting taken down oh man
I I'm so here for keeping me too
absolutely yeah uh they think that they
can pay off Republicans they can hire
GOP AIDS and that is going to be
satisfactory for their customers who are
upset with them as a brand so clearly
what we can see where I think we agree
is that Anheuser-Busch is a faceless
Corporation with no real values that is
willingness willing to spit in the faces
of the little guy if it earns him a
profit they're a trash company and
nobody should buy their products the
left and the right both agree here here
Unity for once I hope they fail same
thing with Disney keep going after
Disney absolutely take Disney down I'm
all for the right wing taking on Disney
all for the right wing taking on
Anheuser-Busch yes of course these are
terrible corporations I'm all
here for it
um by the way the Daily Mail is like the
number one source on the show right like
every single time you pulled it up
because that same site that you showed
me all sides media bias it has the Daily
Mail on right wing and I know that you
yourself when you absolutely fantastic
but if you use them as a primary source
you understand why I'd say that like we
don't use them as a primary source okay
what happens is when we when we pull up
stories
I'll I'll go to like CNN the New York
Times The Wall Street Journal Fox News
ABC and they'll each have like 300 words
and then you go to the Daily Mail after
doing a search on on key elements of the
story and the Daily Mail will have like
seven different versions of all breaking
down different components like if you
scroll down The Daily Mail they often do
these special sections where they have
entirely different stories within the
story providing more context like for
instance this story from the Daily Mail
not only talks about the current story
with the CEO but it even goes all the
way into all of the context going back
to the commercial that was was released
the the sale drop at six percent in the
first week to the video it like covers
literally every even as a photo of the
VP and her husband how in-depth this
story is so it's like if I'm gonna pull
up a single article I can pull up five
ABC CBS New York Times or I can just
pull this one that has seemingly
everything including Kid Rock including
John Rich including Bud Light being
poured into a dumpster it's a massive
aggregate later yeah but honestly I have
no problem with y'all going after uh
Bud Light not have a time go
nuts um I have a really big problem with
what I feel on this show is a lot of
anti-trans Hysteria and fear-mongering
that takes place don't open that book uh
I have that book at home we can talk
about that in a second and I'm totally
comfortable talking about that book I've
read it
um should it be in schools I want to
talk to you about the trans issue though
because that's great that's why I asked
about the book okay we can get to the
books in the schools the curriculums and
everything that the Florida's taken away
but you are you profess to be kind of
like fact based science-based right yeah
like you pull up I've noticed you want
to pull up stats and figures and stuff
like that of course why is it that you
push propaganda when it comes to trans
people like what that is so far beyond
the pale like what okay let's start with
gender for firming care gender affirming
care you're very very against I've heard
you call it utilize it the utilize like
population I don't call mutilation I've
never said that that's what you say on
your shirt I don't know if he does I
call it I know children I call it child
sex change
when you were talking about Dwyane Wade
moving his family someone in the crowd
said why are you mutilating your son
that was a quote from someone else I
didn't say that I call it but then I've
explicitly said I don't take the right
agitator approach of calling it
mutilation because that's not effective
in having a conversation I will plainly
call it a child sex change as what it is
I'm not going to call it gender
affirming or mutilation because I don't
think those things accurate accurately
explain what it is okay so when it comes
to gender affirming care zero two about
talking about child sex change no I'm
talking about gender zero two about ten
years the answer is yes you got to
Define it okay because if you're talking
about something different tell us what
you're talking about all right so if
someone is trans and they are young and
until they're about 10 years old before
they go through puberty gender affirming
care would be in the form of you using
different pronouns preferred pronouns
and allowing them to dress differently
yeah I don't care about that do you have
a problem with that here yes I do I
don't I don't okay so both of you don't
right okay so do you accept that there
is no surgery being performed on
children at that age from 0 to about 10
there's nothing there's no hormone
blockers there's no Purity there is
hormone blockers I don't think surgery
is happening okay so armor under 12. so
hormone blockers aren't given to
Children until they go through puberty
that's not true we actually pull this up
with Destiny he actually he actually
called that I was wrong about a stat
okay what we found was 47
um cross-sex hormones I think it was
something like 17 000 puberty blockers
and like 2 000 double mastectomies for
girls after the age of uh of 13 or
whatever but uh so it doesn't apply to
anything I just said puberty blockers
were pre-teen uh puberty blockers yes
because they have to give them the
people before puberty starts of course
right so so you okay so you're just
referring what I just said from zero to
ten until about you're about to go
through puberty gender affirming care
only comes in the form of using
different pronouns using different names
allowing them to dress differently and
that's it and you don't have a problem
with that we're a Lupron too okay so
we'll get to Lupron but up to that point
you don't have a problem with any of
this yet right I'm saying and you agree
that there is no surgery being performed
on children at that age
let me just start from beginning so I
can make sure I'm getting what you're
saying right yeah I don't care if
parents call their kids names or
whatever I I care about medical or
surgical intervention okay so that
doesn't happen until about the age of
about 16. that's the average age four
that's that's act but but you're wrong
okay like and and look we had Destiny on
the show we went to great detail about
it there are girls who are 13 who are
getting this done and there was a study
actually it was Canadian I believe 12 to
17. they had several hundred surgeries
performed okay so again I said the
average age but if you want to say that
there are people who get this at 12 that
could be the case who would have it I
think let's start with puberty blockers
Tim Lupron you both have a big problem
with Lupron I don't know a lot about it
but I consider it a medical treatment
yeah yeah we shouldn't be uh giving
Lupron to kids so you don't think you
should give the Uber on the kids why why
don't you want Lupron be given to trans
kids to because it's a puberty blocker
that inhibits the natural function and
development of their body and more
importantly I think think my view is
built upon what we've seen out of Europe
already right so earlier on maybe a few
years ago I was more agnostic on the
issue until Sweden Denmark Finland
abandoned this and the Tavistock Center
got got shut down and the data they
released said this actually caused more
harm than good and then I was like well
okay hey how about that and for some
reason United States they're still
hell-bent on moving forward with what we
can already see from you know better
countries with Better Health Care
Systems saying no to this right okay so
I can address those individually because
I have the explanation as to why that
happened when it comes to Lupron 0 to 10
is about the age where gender affirming
care only comes in the form of different
names pronouns stuff like that we can
all agree that's completely fine
I don't fine okay fine but it's their
show so I just want to comments
my position is more just like man like
social therapy stuff uh they say that
after puberty desistance rates are
between 60 65 and like 92 percent so
that's completely false I I I'll get to
that
10 10 follow-up studies found existence
of 61 to 98 yeah can you can you click
on the Wikipedia article
de-transition topics oh you're missing
the mic can't hear you oh sorry what are
the studies what are we talking about I
would like to know if you were taking
these studies specific well because I
have each one of them written down here
and I'm quite curious is the Drummond
study one of them is the Wallen study
estenzma the Swedish study a part of
this the 2011 study
probably I don't know well we should
know this is incredibly important for me
it's not this is 2018. this is uh gender
dysphorian adolescence current
perspectives in the National Library of
Medicine okay scroll down to the
conclusion of this one let me get the
mic again oh so you can carry it around
yeah yeah move it I gotta get you got to
get used to this yeah dog
I know scroll down to the conclusion of
the study oh yeah I mean I want to at
least skim some of the what the numbers
in reference are to like the reference
while you're skimming I when I think of
a little key
like disorders I'm a girl the parent I I
would hope that the parent would be like
you can be you you can pretend to be
whatever you want you can be an actor
you can play a girl but I get afraid
when a mom's like he said he's a girl
that means he's trans right so for this
it's not a process it doesn't exist in
which someone can say hey I'm a boy I'm
a girl and then they go into a doctor's
office and like well take some Lupron
it's you do you do years and years of
consultation between that doctor and and
between like a therapist and between the
patients itself I'm just going to read
this sure of course adolescence is a
crucial time for identity and
psychosexual development in young people
with gender identity concerns the
outcomes of GDC have been discussed in
terms with its pers of its persistence
and desistence for most children with
GDC whether GD will persist or desist
will probably be determined between the
ages of 10 and 13 years although some
may need more time evidence from the 10
available perspective follow-ups studies
from childhood to adolescence reviewed
in the study by restori and Steensma
indicate that foreign
of children who meet the criteria for
GDC right but you said you said 2011. oh
so there's multiple uh steen's studies
they've actually built upon each other
and the problem with the students must
study unfortunately is that they
actually
characterized people who were not Trans
in that study they didn't compare people
who were trans to people who were trans
and then transitioned they compared
people in the general population
for that the actual author of the study
has come out since and said that what
kind of said that the study what can I
pull up to confirm that okay like
because look I pulled up a study that
said a thing you've made a counterclaim
I'll love I will pull it up no no
absolutely yeah okay so go to because I
don't know who esteem is okay so well
students and the problem I'll say one
more thing is I had this written down
45.3 of the people did not reapply for
treatment they counted that as people
who were detransitioning when they
weren't in fact doing that
um
yes
we're literally talking about resistance
right if they're including people who
desisted you'd have to get the numbers
they included people who did not reapply
for treatment they counted that as
someone who was desisting that's just
someone who didn't show up against
that's that's that you do not literal
whatsoever Tim that is someone who has
decided they just don't want to go talk
to that doctor or experience things with
that doctor they could have gone off to
a different doctor they could have done
something else but that is not someone
who has verifiably said I was trans I'm
no longer trans that's just people who
do not show up your thing okay so go to
transadvocate.com I'm not going to uh I
need a study or something not an
advocacy website okay I pulled up a
scientific study for you I'm not pulling
up a non-profit good job so this is an
interview with the person who did the
study in this article I have pulled up a
scientific study for you and the person
who did and I'm challenging you with the
person who did the study and
then you're telling me to pull up an
advocacy website which is not on par
with a scientific study but it's it's
featuring the person who did the science
is there a counter study saying this is
not correct okay if uh yes an OverWatch
like oh okay sure let me pull that up
okay can you like okay look if I pull up
the net the NIH sure and then you say go
to transadvocate.com let's do this cool
Cornell University I'm not going to
Breitbart for my source on assistance
okay sounds good Cornell University did
a meta study let me well what is it okay
according to the university did a meta
study on 55 different studies we'll
start looking up Cornell University meta
study on D transition Cornell University
did a meta study on 55 different studies
on detransitioning of those 55 they
found 52 of the studies showed that
people detransitioned at a rate of less
than four percent and of those people
who did it the reason they
de-transitioned was social stigma that's
52 of the 55. the other three of those
they didn't show a net negative effect
there was not a single study of the 55
the Cornell University looks at that
showed detransitioning or gender
affirming care being a bad thing for
Trans people if anything it was a net
positive
this is a meta study of a whole bunch of
studies I have another medicine I want
to pull up a scientific study to confirm
what you're saying yeah I also just want
to ask a question about this too so
you're mentioning that this is a a
meta-analysis of studies on people who
have detransitioned but by definition
right this is taking into account people
who went through what puberty blockers
hormone replacement therapy physical
surgeries sure for each study was
different things in some of the studies
there was people who were going through
uh puberty blockers some had hormone
therapy but a lot of them in one form or
another had received gender affirm and
care they were trans when the study
first uh tried to identify these people
and then it looked at them years later
and how is this sample collected because
almost every single issue or almost
every single study I've seen from trans
Advocates on this issue use a
convenience sample rather than doing
some kind of controlled randomized test
right so this is a meta study of a whole
bunch of other studies so you would have
to go between each study because at the
end of the day I don't want to film this
trap that me and Tim were about to do
where each of us starts saying like well
I have a study well you have a study
well I have a study we can do this all
day so we should look at metadata right
we should look at compromising data that
looks over bunch of studies a second
made another study that I want you to
look at regret after gender affirming
surgery a systematic review and
meta-analysis of prevalence this went to
Canada the Netherlands Belgium UK Italy
USA Brazil Sweden Singapore Germany
Norway Ireland Serbia and an interview
between 27 studies
7928 trans patients it showed a less
than one percent right regret waiting
okay I got to address this right now
there is a problem we are facing in that
you are saying a lot of things and I
can't pull up any sources
at the very least all I did was Google
searched it I pulled up the two studies
that were associated with it and said
here's what it says I have not given you
my personal perspective on it you've now
given me your personal view on it no
I've given you the studies these are two
medicines that studies let me please
pull them up I can't find what you're
talking about the first one is Cornell
University they did a meta study what's
the name of it it's Cornell University's
meta study of 72 studies on gender
affirming care of that 55 of the studies
were directly related to detransaging
what met a study on
Cornell University what does scholarly
research say about the effect of gender
transition or on gender trans well-being
oh here we go I found it nice
and the third one the third meta study
that I want to bring up is a U.S study
it's a 2015 U.S transgender but this
isn't this isn't a scientific research
paper that's peer-reviewed uh no this is
a meta-analysis of scientifically
research Pages
hold on like do we have a standard on
why we why should why should we we
should there's if you want to know their
methodology there's a click here to view
the methodology thing you can find that
out for yourself right there but this is
not a peer-reviewed scientific paper
this is a meta-analysis too okay
so if you want to check that out bro
next thing you're going to do you're
going to tell me Ivermectin is some cure
because of that analysis
you can't come to me when everyone tries
screaming about Ivermectin because of a
meta-analysis that I reject and say I
don't think it works
meta-analysis is effective now the point
is this I said give me a study and you
cannot do it I am on my way to give you
a third meta study of cities these are
cuties no if we go study to study back
and forth Tim this is going to take
forever one one study one study
one study one dude I'm giving you two
give me one this is embarrassing I've
got like embarrassing you can't give me
one study okay I've given you two and I
didn't even make an assortment I Googled
it and pulled up what individual studies
I said about analysis which is
ridiculous but sure here's individual
studies the mental health outcomes in
transgender non-binary non-binary youth
receiving gender different Urban care
from February 25th 2022. this shows let
me type it in and pull it up oh yeah but
I can explain to them while you're doing
your own research kids
mental health outcomes mental health
outcomes in transgender and non-binary
youth receiving some different care
February 25th 2022 peer-reviewed study
the findings kids who receive puberty
blockers and hormone therapy had 60
lower odds of moderate or severe
depression and 73 lower odds of
suicidality here's another individual
study for you hold on hold on that that
nothing to do with resistance
do you do you want to go back to
resistance studies that's what I was
asking you about
I I Google searched assistance Wikipedia
I've got two studies that say it's 61 to
98 you said that's wrong I said you
didn't give me one I did on the spot you
gave it we're on camera so yeah it's not
a peer review if you want to go back and
forth to him on single studies like I
said this can take forever so it it it
do not have a single study I've named
you tons of studies no no no you've
given me a meta-analysis not a single
stuff a meta-analysis combines other
studies do you understand how that works
yeah of that stuff
you're saying that out of 72 studies
that found a conclusion
that's 72 55 talked about it it was it
was a hypothetical number 51. you're
looking at a bunch of studies that have
come to conclusions of course that are
peer-reviewed and you're saying but
someone uh analyzed those questions
who from Cornell click on click here to
view right methodology you just rejected
it out right when you saw it you were
like
a meta-analysis of studies these are
different things the problem is these
Studies have their own conclusions
you're ignoring they combine their
conclusions to reach them I mean let me
let me let me explain for those that
want to understand what I'm trying to
say during covid there were a whole
bunch of studies done individual studies
peer reviewed that found Ivermectin did
not work the right kept bringing up
meta-analyzes that said actually it does
I said and I said this to Joe Rogan I
reject that show me the actual study I
do not believe this is correct I will
not afford you some benefit to come in
and make the same argument to me if you
do not have a study that is Pyramid
incited then I'm not going to entertain
your provides opinions so when I bring
up the Cornell University City that's
that's not a study it's a meta-analysis
yeah a 55 peer-reviewed studies whose
conclusion of 52 came to the fact that
there's a less than 4 four percent
detransition rate if you go to R science
Tim you can find out
you're pulling up Reddit when I'm
uh berniever last name is pronounced
explains and and downplays why you're
wrong about that 80 to 85 because she's
the one who actually did that study
she's the one who did the study you
cited so so she explains why it's being
misused it is not true I can say this
there are arguments about what is true
all day every day there is arguments
that M Theory is wrong and that science
is unwilling to give up because too many
scientists have dedicated their lives to
it so they argue that M Theory is the is
is the theory While others are coming up
with like E8 Lie group Theory or
whatever I totally understand that
people will decide what they think is
true or not hence I have a bottom line
standard if the Right comes at me and
says Ivermectin meta-analyzes prove it
works I say don't know don't care we
have rejected the concept of someone
analyzing a collection of studies and
making determination what our standard
is at the very least where I'm at is if
we're going to have any basic agreement
on what is or isn't there has to be a
unified standard there which is a
peer-reviewed study which is not
absolute if I have two peer-reviewed
studies and the establishment narrative
when I search for it says 61 to 98
percent
I will not accept your meta-analysis
opinion the same as I wouldn't for
someone who believes Ivermectin works
because your argument is founded upon
the same basis as theirs okay so first
off the meta-analysis of iramectin
actually showed that it wasn't effective
at preventing or treating covet 19. that
was the actual meta-analysis in
Ivermectin so it actually would back up
your own uh claims secondly you and me
can look at individual studies and it
can take a very long time but we should
look at regret after gender affirming
surgery a systematic review and
meta-analysis of prevalence which looks
at again 27 studies and interviews 7928
trans people across the world and again
in places like Italy USA Brazil you name
it that meta-analysis also found a less
than one percent regret rate you have to
be able to combine multiple studies
because this is something that has been
so thoroughly investigated globally for
so long that to ignore the science and
data on this is is too flagrantly well
there's not been a single large-scale
randomized clinical trial for puberty
blockers to treat gender dysphoria
there's not been one you all are very
against Lupron right well I don't know
much about it I know I I just vary
against it's pretty strong okay I'm
typically like we shouldn't give I'm
saying there hasn't been one large-scale
randomized clinical trial
Lupron for when when children go through
like the early onset puberty yeah and
it's like an actual medical issue like
of course that's why saying very against
something is like well what we're
talking about is are are we are we going
to a kid who are we dealing with an
actual case of say endocrine disruption
caused by phthalates and pcbs or are we
dealing with a kid who's just playing
with dolls and the parents are incorrect
right and in that case you would have a
long process where they would have to do
interviews with the professionals who
would determine whether or not it's
appropriate and people will go on
puberty blockers I want to add this it's
for a limited amount of time they want
to do it only to be able to hold that
off no it isn't if you see this is the
actual doctors on this you only take it
no no Tim let me finish the sentence
come on you brought me on your show let
me finish this you only go on puberty
blockers for a short amount of time
before you can be put onto HRT they do
not want to keep them on puberty
blockers and that way you avoid a lot of
the potential negative side effects
Helena kirschner on the show who walked
into a Planned Parenthood and within
minutes was given the maximum dose of
testosterone anecdote absolutely so when
I say limited experience happens you say
it doesn't happen it's like it did
happen no I'm saying it can't happen you
have to look at the broader data you
have to look at broader details I take
right yeah and it wouldn't make sense if
I brought up a single Horror Story to
you and said this is fact it can happen
I said we don't want that to happen of
course no one wants that to happen but
then if we want to understand how this
is actually taking place around the
world from an actual perspective of
science we have to look at the data we
have to look at meta studies we have to
look at the and analyze Global uh
understanding of this when it comes to
Lupron by example yes it's true that
Lupron is not FDA approved for the use
of uh on cisgender children there is a
product that is FDA approved for use
with children that is a puberty blocker
and it has been used for a long time for
generations and decades
it's Lupron it was just being done no
but that's an entirely different reason
that's for an entirely different reason
so to say we want to present is to say
we want to prevent a child from
undergoing early onset puberty so that
they can develop any normal healthy rate
it's entirely different it is entirely
different from saying we're going to
administer puberty blockers because this
child fears feels they're a member of
the opposite sex whether that's an
entirely different
reasons is is going to be the problem
right you want to know whether or not
it's used it's going to be dangerous
about children and and the reason for
administering a certain treatment can
render it dangerous
so for example if we have been
amputating people's limbs for hundreds
of years if I go into a doctor and say
please cut my arm off because I don't
want it anymore and he cuts my arm off
that's medical malpractice for you to
jump in and go we have been cutting
people's arms off for hundreds of years
this is medically approved people are
allowed to do this it's not yes
absolutely so what you're describing is
called biid body identity uh disorder I
forget how it's spelled um it is a real
phenomenon yes it's extremely rare but
we know enough about it at this point to
know that people will seek out to get
operations on the black market if they
have biid and what we've found when
people do that and go to the black
market to have a limb removed is that it
only provides a temporary amount of
relief for their condition and then it
returns and they have further
complications from the fact that they
now have a disability and or medical
complications that come from my point is
not about any kind of body dysmorphia
about losing a limb my point is about
drawing a false my point is about
drawing a false conclusion by a medical
treatment being allowed under
circumstance a but not being allowed
under circumstance B you're saying we
allow it for kids who have hit
precocious puberty but then we don't
allow it for kids who don't want to go
for through puberty it's still not FDA
approved but you understand my point I
just claim those things are the same I
just Google searched it real quick stat
in 2017 100 out of 100 with News Guard
drug used to Halt puberty may cause
lasting health problems more than ten
thousand adverse event reports were
filed with the FDA reflecting the
experience of women who've taken Lupron
describing everything from brittle bones
to faulty joints
you know regarding meta meta-analyzes
like I I'm worried about you know
giving kids things on an experimental
basis yeah this is a huge long
conversation and it would be so awesome
to go through each study I would love to
it would probably take like seven hours
six hours but we could do it but like
not tonight unfortunately so let me ask
you though but I want to keep down this
path because I think yeah we're making
good progress let me ask you a question
like like jazz Jennings is sterile right
she's a reality TV show right Jazz
Jennings yeah I'm I'm concerned that
jazz isn't trans uh that's not for us to
say uh I didn't say I said I'm concerned
that jazz is not trans right and the
reason is jazz is dating women now right
so then Jasmine doesn't have to do with
being trans well Jazz would then be a
biological male dating woman at the age
of 23. what does it have to do with
being friends so it has to do with
whether or not Jazz made the decision
for themselves or the parent made it
when they were three years old so the
question is
we want to avoid a John money type
situation right where you had these two
kids and the doctor told one of the
young boys he was actually a girl and
then forced him to live as a girl
ultimately resulting in his suicide and
then the death of the brother as well we
don't want that to happen and so that
did happen already and we know that
happened so we have to be careful about
taking a three-year-old and then raising
them and telling them they're female
because then if they start exhibiting
traditional uh uh you know gender
behaviors there may be some concern for
instance Jazz stopped dilating and that
was the big controversy over the past
few weeks the mother going on TV saying
she would force Jazz to do it if jazz is
saying I'm not gonna and the mother's
saying do it or I'll ring your neck
which is a quote and then jazz is now
dating women we're starting to see a
pattern that may be concerning because
it follows the John money situation
whether or not jazz is trans or not my
concern is uh oh what if and that means
there may be children who are going to
be pushed down a path that ultimately
leads to their suicide because their
parents can't make the decision for them
but they did so the data overwhelmingly
shows that if you give children gender
firming care especially if you have
loving and accepting parents who accept
children's actual gender identity it
reduces the rates of suicide
dramatically in the case of a parent who
affirms their child's gender can reduce
suicide rates of up to 93 percent in
some studies it's it's not a case of uh
more often than not these are children
who are approaching their parents saying
they think this is something happening
to them and parents pushing back and
being like no this is wrong you're just
a tomboy oh this is you know this is not
you this is and you don't go into a
doctor and all of a sudden they're like
here's Lupron they do no but they don't
Tim the average amount of time the
average amount of time can't say they
don't when we've had the anecdotes they
do call it an anecdote it's not telling
you it does happen of course but that's
an anecdote we have to look at it so you
don't say it statistics well it happens
but that doesn't mean it's a broad trip
not happened right but that's okay this
this is awesome we have to talk about
what actually occurs via the numbers
right that's that's what matters like I
I have here the largest U.S transgender
survey ever done it's in 24 2015 to 21
598 participants and this covers people
in childhood adolescence and adulthood
and it has all the results you're
looking for so let me ask you a question
why do you think we're seeing the increa
a rapid increase in the past few years
of young people identifying as trans
okay
yeah of course so it shows the 2015 U.S
transgender survey of 21 598
participants that with hormone therapy
psychological distress for children
reduces by 222 percent laid adolescence
153 adulthood 81 suicidal ideation for
children goes down 135 percent for uh
adolescents 62 and for adults 21 is that
that is dramatic is this the Stanford
Medical School survey analysis done by
Jack turban uh I do know the person who
did it okay but in terms of the the
increase Tim of people because there's a
because there was a study done by
Stanford Medical School that very
closely fits the description of what
you've just read out there which is very
a scientifically yeah so just just
please
because I want I want to pull that apart
but I want to be sure that I know you're
talking about that study I'm curious as
to why you think it's it's increasing so
much
what's that what's that signify
the history of left-handedness this is
the history of left-handedness in the
United States do you see what happens
here it levels out it goes up levels we
used to we used to treat people who were
left-handed as satanic as the devil all
that kind of you remember that
right and that's why there was a lot of
people who didn't record themselves as
being left-handed and then boom when we
stopped doing that after the 1880s and
in the 1900s it spiked now this Spike
isn't because there was a whole bunch of
indoctrination or Alex Jones was like oh
left-handed ideology everyone has become
this has nothing to do with that this is
naturally how many left-handed people
there were and then it plateaued we are
in a situation right now where it is
safer than ever for people to come out
and if they're queer bisexual whatever
it is and because of that they feel
safer expressing that that's why gen
Zone there was a trans genocide yeah so
here's this is this is the actual
statistics on people increasing you can
see the red one that is Gen Z that is
the amount of people who are in gen Z
it's skyrocketing it looks like they're
identifying more than ever because their
generation feels more comfortable
talking about this kind of stuff so you
don't say but there's like a
transgenocide or anything like that I
don't think that there's a trans
indoctrination that is coming through
media yes and I'm saying that I don't
think there's a trans-indoctrination
coming through media that is programming
kids to become trans I think that's
ridiculous so and if you want to change
topics to talk about trans genocide we
can move on to that but but you asked me
specifically why is there why is there a
spike that is why okay so my follow-up
is you think trans people feel safer
than ever no right now there's over 400
different bills being pushed in the
United States that is directly targeting
trans people so they don't feel safe
they of course they don't so then why
are they coming out if they don't feel
safe they have more access because that
Generation generation Z has a lot more
acceptance towards trans people than
older people who pass laws Draconian
people who pass laws the boomers are the
ones running the show right now they're
still the ones in government that are
still the one passing laws there's very
few Generations Z in government or
Parliament you know you want to know
what I think I think there is a
transgenocide okay and I think it's you
okay because you're sterilizing a lot of
these people also I mean you're
literally sterilizing them they're
refrigerator remove the gonads
hysterectomies and puberty and cross-sex
hormones and puberty blockers have a
high rate of sterilization I mean first
of all uh removal of the gonads in the
uterus is an absolute sterilization and
then puberty blockers have a very high
rate uh and uh cross-ex hormones have
extremely high rate of sterilizing the
individual so these people can no longer
reproduce that's genocide
so is this the joke you can go for joke
you are removing these people's ability
to reproduce and if they're a young age
and they haven't had the ability like
for instance Jazz Jennings can never
have kids jazz Jennings also in this
this probably part of your studies can't
actually feel any said like sexual uh
feeling of any kind do you have any idea
how weird this sounds right now like why
are you what about the stranger's
genital pleasure that's so weird that's
so bizarre that was very weird yourself
you guys are all right so I'm talking
about adults who engage in activities
which is a large portion of the global
economy whether you like it or not sex
cells they say and when I say this
person will never have this ability you
go how weird is that it's weird for you
to fixate on a stranger's genital
pleasure that's strange that's so
bizarre well she's public about it but
see that's you're not making an argument
right now is my point I'm not I'm saying
it's weird it's not an argument that's
an observation so you're trying to make
an appeal to emotion and an appeal I'm
just I'm just giving you my genuine
thought when you say something like that
that it was a really pathetic
why should we discuss whether or not she
has genital feeling that's not important
it's not that it's not in my business so
let's focus that on the sterilizing of
the individual are you okay with that
when who's sterilizing people Jazz
Jennings is sterile why are we going
back to Justin because yeah I don't know
anything about her because Jazz is a
famous individual on cable television so
if she is steroidal for whatever reason
what does that have to do with me why
does that concern me why should I pass
the sterilization of teenagers
this is such a weird way to frame this
like you are removing teenagers ability
to have children I'm not doing anything
I'm not a doctor too
right I support people having access to
health care of course why would I want
to prevent that just because some people
have bigotry towards them let's try
again you seem scared of this do you
believe that parents and doctors should
have the ability to remove the ability
of a child for for future reproduction
they should have the ability to give
them access to health care of course
they should so why did you you're you're
implying that every single gender
affirming care results in sterilization
that is that is not true at all the
removal there's also people who are
trans that never get bottoms you're very
scared of this it's scaring you how how
am I afraid to because you keep
deflecting when I ask you so Jazz
Jennings is a specific reflecting all
right let's try this all right let's
slow down and go one point at a time you
think I'm deflecting because I don't
want to keep talking about someone's
genital pleasure who's a stranger
things
Tim your appeal to emotions not going to
work on me I'm asking you a sign I know
I can appeal to your emotion I'm trying
a logic based question about the future
of of these people I believe you are
genociding them I believe you and you
intend on genociding autistic
individuals I genuinely believe that
who's autistic is this a large portion
of trans kids are autistic namely
females so this is an issue in that
young lesbian autistic females are a
large portion of those who are
transgender do you have job data on this
I mean come on bro do you have data on
what you've brought up you couldn't give
me one study but yeah I've given you not
only studies I've given you multiple
meta studies on this I I've given you a
surplus of information on this topic
make up six six times more likely to
have autism according to npr.org so I
think you're trying to genocide autistic
people I I literally what's the
percentage of that's what I asked you
six times sixty percent that's not how
that works that's not you don't you
don't 600 sorry no that's not how that
works you're saying what percent of that
what percentage of trans people happen
to be autistic lesbians that was your
claim that a large portion are I'm
saying I don't know any statistics on
that I've never heard that before right
so uh the first thing I pulled up was
that transgender and non-binary
non-binary people up to six times more
likely to have autism right right but
that's not answering the question yet
and your question is what portion of let
me Google it again
because I thought that was sufficient in
me and you know uh
24 percent
so that's not the majority even if that
stat is true six times more common 24
that's still not the majority even if
that statistic was true yeah no I that
the majority is 25 24 of trans people
are autistic according to that data and
six percent of so so what I think is I
think that there is there are people who
hate people with Down syndrome and in
Iceland they've actually publicly a
vowed or or praised their eradication of
people with Down Syndrome I think that's
horrifying like you can you can be you
can be okay with it I'm not saying
you're not allowed to believe that right
you don't have to have the same morals
as me I just think it's wrong to
genocide like people with Down Syndrome
you know what I mean you have completely
derailed this conversation you're
assuming that I'm Pro people having uh
abortions for people who have Down
syndrome when we're talking about I'm
not saying you do I'm saying in Iceland
they've always have to do with trans
rights right so we see a higher rate of
autistic people uh autism and trans kids
it makes it the majority it does not
even basically hold up okay 24 okay uh I
still believe that this is very much an
effort I think I think the left is
intent on genociding trans people in
what way removing their ability to
reproduce
how are they removing their ability by
cutting off their testicles and removing
that is not the only operation that is
done there are trans people who maintain
their same genitals as before right
everyone has to decide to get bottom
surgery that's the choice they should
make and cross-ex hormones do have a
high rate of causing sterilization it
can but it doesn't always
get any operations at all so I think you
are so like I'm in favor of making sure
these people can always have families
and have kids right
your position whether you support the
Moral Moral issue of or not results in
many of them being stale for instance
the reason I use Jazz standing as an
example because this is a person on
television with millions of followers
who wrote a book and told kids about
this journey the journey that jazz
Jennings went on resulted in a complete
inability to have a family and have
children
I think that's terrifying because Jazz
was not old enough to understand the
implications of that jazz will never
have a family Jazz the the the genetics
of jazz Jennings is over
that is one of the most horrifying
things to me as a human being because I
think genocide is wrong right why should
her ability to be or have reproduction
function why should that concern you for
the same reason the uyghur Muslims in
China concern me like human rights
issues China for instance what if she
never wants to have kids that's
something you determine for yourself
later in life exactly so why is it our
business because it's been removed
before Jazz could have the ability but
again the conclusion that has nothing to
do with us she could decide to never
want to have kids and that's fine and
valid so my morals would be that a a
society protects the children because
there are certain things you can't know
until you're at least 24 or older when
your brain is fully developed which is
why we don't allow people to drink and
do like do certain drugs whatever drugs
are legal until they're 21. so for me
I'm like if you can't drink till you're
eight till you're 21 if they're slight
you can't smoke till you're 18. this
Society absolutely recognize you can't
drive to a certain age that uh the
reason that the driving age is is what
it is one of the arguments made I think
it was in Illinois is that risk taking
is a lot higher in youth than it is in
older people so the argument is once
you're past 16 you go through driver Zed
that helps uh control for the higher
risk taking of of younger people
somebody's at an age limit
for someone who's 10 years old to be put
on Lupron and then cross-sex hormones
they will never develop the ability to
reproduce so in the instance of jazz
again a famous individual who's very
influential with millions of followers
there was never the ability to reproduce
developed which caused complications
complications aside that's Jazz's
personal business but the the puberty
blockers and crosstormones did sterilize
Jets 100 sterilization Jazz was not old
enough to understand the implications of
that so I I have concerns about having
children whether they choose or their
parents choose to
I think that's genocide I can kind of
see your argument because if a kid was
straight a straight kid just a kid and
they were like a 12 year old girl and
she was like I don't want to have babies
when I'm older and the mom was like okay
then we'll sterilize you right now and
they went and had the kid had a
hysterectomy that's I think that's
illegal I don't know but I would imagine
Society needs to protect uh little
little kids from crazy parents that are
like just because a 12 year old says
they don't have babies later so the fact
that it is sterilizing as a byproduct I
think should be should be taken into
account with the whole procedure
I think that's something that comes down
to the individual and what they choose
to do and if someone is like I want to
have gender affirming care knowing the
risks then why is that my business it's
the same thing with someone who wants to
have a surgery that can have other
complications that's not my business if
someone had an appendix a flamed and
they had to have their appendix out
there are potential complications that
come from that but I'm not going to
prevent them from having health care and
saying that you can't have a right to
get your appendix out because every
Major Medical Association in the United
States agrees that that is the best way
to treat appendicitis and in this case
when we're talking about trans people
every single Medical Association in the
United States agrees on gender affirming
care then you know what every single one
you know what they should do they should
produce one single randomized controlled
trial for puberty blockers and Crosses
cross sex hormones to show that it's
safe and effective but they have not so
it's not health care it's
experimentation
you talk about giving kids health care
that's not Health Care Health Care
repair is something which is broken you
use the example of somebody's appendix
not functioning properly yeah of course
okay so what you have to do in that
instance is intervene so that the body
can function as as it is intended to
destroying somebody's ability to
procreate
is demolishing the organ that you're
claiming to treat right you're
destroying the biological function
rather than helping to improve it that's
not health care I want to pull this up
too it's from University of Utah because
I was reading about this recently it's
it goes on to mention that hormone
replacement therapy can make you sterile
uh and that it's important it can it's
important to preserve your sperm it says
if you're trans feminine uh otherwise
the hormone therapy may make you make it
impossible for you to have biological
children uh if someone is put on puberty
blockers and then cross-ex hormones as a
child they will never have the ability
to preserve their their reproductive
functions so if you're putting puberty
blockers they are reversible you can
stop being on puberty blockers and you
can still maintain a lot of things that
you were worried about being taken away
when it comes to Jennings specifically
um she's actually made statements about
this because you know I was just looking
this up judge Jennings says I don't
regret my transition at all when I was
11 I started male puberty and I was put
on hormone blockers those blockers saved
my life and continued to save the lives
of so many youth out there if I was
forced to go to through male puberty it
would have been devastating even more so
taking estrogen through hormone
replacement allowed my body to develop
how I wanted I blossomed into a young
woman eventually got bottom surgery and
now living as a proud woman today what
does that have to do with me why would I
want to take that away from someone else
she made this on March 31st she made it
recently because that video came out
where the mom said she was going to
force the dilated Matt Walsh went hard
and jazzed I was like hey Matt and then
I was like sorry there's a there's a lot
of questions around the morality of this
the left likes to refer defer instantly
to Purity arguments which I find
fascinating concerning the left
typically has a low Purity uh rating
when it comes to moral foundations for
example when you said it's really weird
talking about someone's genitals it's a
purity argument which the left typically
never makes that's why I said it's a
very weird thing for you to do
approaching this from an academic
perspective we would make a few
arguments about whether or not a person
can truly understand they've lost the
ability to reproduce if they've never
had in the first place the the
psychological and the philosophical
philosophical implications of stripping
away a person's ability to reproduce
before they were old enough to even know
what that was so uh for example
if you take an adult human female or
male and remove their genitals by force
they will be very very upset extremely
upset in fact it's a form of torture in
a lot of countries it's meant to terrify
if you took away their ability to feel
sexual satisfaction it's a form of
torture in fact female circumcision is
is horrifying to the world and it
actually was huge controversies up in
Dearborn Michigan because what would do
is it would result in women who are as
adults could not feel anything when and
then they were effectively used as like
objects for their husbands
so in making an academic argument we
would say
Jazz Jennings does not understand and
that's fine if jazz is happy that's
great the the argument into the greater
is jazz will never have kids fact
statement I think it's wrong to take
away that from someone who doesn't
understand what it is they don't want
kids they will decide that when they're
an adult and have assessed the
circumstances but Jazz can't actually
feel any of this jazz jazz can't feel uh
this is this was a study there's a
doctor came out did a zoom video on it
specifically I think referring to Jazz
that jazz will never experience any
adult satisfaction or desire and so the
question then becomes why did Jazz get
bottom surgery that's my question why do
you think Jazz got bottom surgery oh I
don't have to ask that she explained why
she said that she said that she's
satisfied with it that should be the
extent of it what did she say
um
I don't regret my transition at all when
I was 11 I started male puberty and I
was put on hormone blockers those
blockers saved my life and continue to
save the lives of so many youth out
there if I was forced to go through male
puberty it would have been devastating
even more taking estrogen through
hormone replacement allowed my body to
develop how I wanted I blossomed into a
young woman eventually got bottom
surgery and I'm living as a proud woman
today yes I do struggle with mental
health and always have but it's not
because I transitioned and it's
unfortunately something many lgbtq plus
people face why because it has a lot to
do with hate and a lack of acceptance
that we receive in society like I was
saying before so to all of you speaking
about our Mental Health reviews and
calling our families abusers for
supporting our transition you are the
only abusers so what was the purpose of
the bottom surgery it affirmed her uh
gender it affirmed her gender what does
that mean affirm to gender so you have
and all of us have a gender identity
that we want to express in one way or
another and with hers she affirmed her
gender through the process of getting
bottom surgery to look more and feel
more like a woman why do you think Jazz
stopped dilating I don't know
probably because it hurt
but if if this was an important part of
affirmation you'd think Jazz would
maintain it
that's not for me to decide that someone
else's own identity so again that's why
it's weird to me to try and impose this
upon someone else like to try and say
like a year disgusted at the fact that
she can't have kids or something like
that it's like I don't know if she ever
wants kids because I don't know who she
is but that's a decision for her to make
between her and her doctor has nothing
to do with why would any uh trans child
get a bottom surgery again to affirm
their gender so as part of gender I mean
care why children don't get bottom
surgery by the way it's usually over 18.
well Jazz was 17. and so there are
exceptions yes but the average average
age is
like Boston Boston's Children's Hospital
has never done that on anyone under the
age of 18. the average age for bottom
surgery is over 18 years old so
overwhelmingly why why would uh I I just
don't understand why the um it's not
penile inversion vaginal plastic I don't
know what it's called because Jazz
didn't have a penis uh what's the
purpose of making a a a a a the whole
the space what's the purpose of of that
what's the the operation is because it
gives them uh it affirms their gender
through the process of having a similar
genitalia to a CIS woman
so what's the purpose of it I just
explained that so the purpose of it is
just feeling just the emotion no the
purpose of it it is part of affirming
who they are through a surgery that
makes them look and feel more like a a
version of a woman that they want to be
you don't have to there's not a template
that's not the only version a woman can
be there's other versions of how a woman
can be and look but that's the version
that she wanted
so what I'm trying to understand is
why create
a permanent wound
for the purpose of a man to have sex
with in order to affirm the identity of
someone who can't feel any of that well
first off I have no idea about the
actual Sensations that people experience
after these kind of surgeries but that's
not my business and the second thing
would be I don't believe it's a wound I
believe it's an operation to have a
genital change that's it so describe it
as a wound it's just very crude but it's
factually a wound right that's I'm
trying to avoid the right the right
calls it immutilation or an Abomination
I'm not saying that but it's still crude
to just call it a wound after it's after
it's healed I'm sure there's no more no
scars dilate for the rest of their lives
because it is a wound
like I'm being academic I'm not trying
to be insulting to anybody the right
calls it mutilation and Abomination the
reason they have to use dilators for the
rest of their lives is because it is
factually a wound but you're asking me a
question that I can't answer because I'm
not this individual I don't know why
someone would want to get that surgery
because I don't I'm CIS and I don't
experience these kind of things but if
someone wants to but Tim if someone
wants to and it makes them feel better
and improves their quality of life then
why do we have to get in the way of that
well my position is for adults I agree
and I had the argument with Tom fit and
he said it should be banned out right I
disagree but overwhelmingly when you
look at the data when it happens to
Children it improves their psychological
distress it removes and lowers suicidal
ideation it shows in the data that it
helps them that's not true man so though
the study you have you're the largest
one so first of all as I mentioned there
have been no controlled randomized trial
but the largest stuff
the largest study that you cited there
does not say what you think it says the
Stanford University one it was 27 000
people who were surveyed in 2015 and
then there were two and now analyzes
done of these Studies by Jack turban and
he lumped data together and did a few
manipulative things to like get the
results he wanted but there's two very
important things to mention which is
firstly this study was based on
convenience sampling so they were
speaking with people who were sent to
them by lgbtq advocacy groups and groups
that they reached out to so you're
already not getting an unbiased
population sample there
and then they were determining whether
that person received puberty blockers
and other such treatments or hadn't but
they didn't go over the reasons in fact
the people who hadn't received puberty
blockers or those kinds of treatments
didn't receive them because they weren't
allowed to and one of the requirements
for being able to receive that kind of
treatment is some level of psychological
stability which means the people who
weren't on puberty blockers in that
study were more likely to be
psychologically unstable which we would
expect to produce a higher suicide rate
but that wasn't controlled for on top of
that the data actually shows that the
men who are on estrogen were more likely
to become suicidal but what he ended up
doing that's true what he ended up doing
was lumping them together so he said
people on cross-sex hormones are less
likely to commit suicide because
according to the sample he had of women
that was true enough to overcompensate
for the increased likelihood of
suicidality in the men and he just threw
them all together as if a man taking
estrogen is the same thing as a woman
taking testosterone and we could expect
the same medical outcomes so I'm saying
that's so so to respond to you
I do have a number of peer-reviewed
studies related to this and if they're
as good as that one I'm telling you
they're trash mental health outcomes and
transgender non-binary youth receiving
gender affirming care February 25th 2022
this one shows kids who receive puberty
blockers and hormone therapy had 60
lower odds of moderate or severe
depression 73 lower odds of suicidality
gender identity five years after social
transition this one is in the American
Academy of Pediatrics peer reviewed July
13 2022 between 317 youth they found 94
binary transgender stayed the same only
2.5 percent reverted to reverting as
cisgender 3.5 as non-binary trans a UK
2019 study of 3 398 people who had
gender ferment care found that only 0.47
regretted it another one the impacts of
strong parental support for Trans youth
found that parents who support trans
youth this was 433 participants
double-blind study 93 reduction in
reported suicides
and I think we can all have the good
faith that you did as much work fact
checking those studies as you did the
one I just tore apart but I didn't have
time to go into every single bit of
statistical information you would bring
here this is this is the problem with
like like you mentioned going the
studies back and forth or whatever so
that's why I'm fine with
I'm not here to change your morals right
and that's fine so my question would
just be why do you think it is that in
Europe they've abandoned these practices
a lot of it was political
if you look at the history of it
especially when it came to puberty
blockers and how that was handled
um it was in large part of political
decision that both
um medical groups Advocates as well as
pro-lgbtq organizations outwardly
um uh protested and especially like I
know you're going to bring up Finland I
believe was one of the countries that it
is Sweden as well uh in the UK yeah and
in a number of cases this is something
in which experts experts in the fields
of Endocrinology uh Pediatrics they were
very opposed to it it was politicians
who were pushing for this and so this
was a political decision this is why I
don't like when politics get directly
involved in medical decisions because I
mean like you were saying if you want to
look up the actual organizations that
support this it's every Major Medical
Association in the United States
everyone without like without fail
a lot of times if you don't get
politically involved in the medical
industry they'll experiment on humans
some of them are some of them are not if
I listed them to you right now because I
have the list you some of these are not
four profit institutions just looking to
make a Buck some of these are
just genuinely concerned about child
health care
and some of them have various I mean
ideological biases this isn't always
about money all the time but if you're
going to reject what's what Tim is
saying about medical institutions no
longer performing these operations in
Nordic Europe because you're claiming
those institutions have become political
I don't know how you could give any
credibility to the American ones so it's
not the most do you think the American
model should production medicine is
better than the modeling let me answer
your question okay it's it's not the
organizations themselves that have done
it distinctly it was politicians and
political organizations as well as think
tanks that were pushing for it and it
was a lot of experts in the field that
directly wanted it not to happen but
then why is it the case that so the the
nation that started doing this
earlier than any of the others was the
Netherlands they started around 1990
administering puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones for children who
purported to be struggling with feelings
of dysphoria and so they have some of
the longest term data available on this
and what they found is that
transitioning has no effect on
suicidality that's part of the studies
that I'm interested is the suicide stuff
like in 2022 they measured a bunch of
people that transitioned they were
suicidal they transitioned now they're
not but it's like hey that was eight
months ago like how are you gonna feel
in four years from now so it's hard to
say like now now they're no longer
suicidal just because they're like yeah
I'm not suicidal now but like we gotta
we need long-term studies we do need to
go to super chats because we're way past
but I do want to ask another just
question like do you think the Earth is
overpopulated
laughs
no I don't you don't think so no I want
more people I love people I want more
birth I Want More Humans I love
everybody man I want more people on this
planet but what about climate change
climate change is coming it's real it's
happening right now but I mean but
you're not malthusian then no yeah okay
but but more people means more climate
change you got more miles to feed you've
got more fuels to burn but more orgasms
it would also means more scientists
that's kind of weird right but more
humans doesn't necessarily mean more
climate change because More Humans might
figure out better ways to balance out
the climate I'll just say one last thing
and we'll go to super chats and then um
I guess I want to try and get to the
members only poor actually man I feel
bad for going long we should go to the
members portion so we can do uh audience
q a and stuff there's some big super
chats in here I'll just I'll try and
grab as many as I can and then we'll
we'll try to just we'll go straight to q
a for the members only portion but my
attitude is very I'm not a conservative
uh I'm pro-choice I think you know I've
got my morality but in the long term I
really don't care that leftists are
sterilizing and aborting their children
I thought you did care from a moral
position but like I'm not a conservative
like like Sheamus where Sheamus is very
much like we have to end this because
you know it's wrong I'm uh I'm I'm not a
conservative I I if if a woman is going
to get an abortion at a certain uh a
certain age I'm like I disagree with it
but I'm more libertarian in the respect
of like people can choose to do what
they want to do I think it's certainly
wrong to sterilize kids but the end
result is
the future is going to be a bunch of
Christian conservatives and Muslims and
so like it's a it's a self if you if yes
but the Jewish population diaspora is
like 12 million and Christians and
Muslims are billions so like but that's
happened in Israel right where the more
religious Jews have more children so
they're dominating elections right
exactly and so we saw this since the
year 2000 liberals have been effectively
shrinking gen Z is the first generation
in 100 years to slightly move towards
conservative in some some areas likely
not because gen Z is becoming
conservative but because there's less
liberal gen zirs than there are
conservative ones so the end result of
all of this is just like look man I'm
not going to convince you to vote the
way I would vote I'm not going to
convince James to vote that way I would
vote but doesn't matter anyway because
in 100 years you guys are sterilizing
and aborting your kids
end of story wait a minute not you well
yeah
I represent the left to him do you do
you feel like you represented I I I
don't I don't feel I represent the left
no you called yourself a left but I am
I'm a proud leftist I wear that I don't
have to hide that I don't hide my Powers
I don't wear uh you know some kind of
like uh hidden my point is just this
right I'm just saying I'm not I'm like
there's no single voice for the left I'm
not I'm not the voice of the left no
sure sure I'm just saying the left will
cease to exist and the middle and the
right will supplant it and then the
middle will become the left and the
right will will stay the right here's
what I'll say is that lgbtq plus people
were heavily persecuted by a lot of
different groups including the Nazis at
one point or another in history and you
just can't give the Communists if you if
you and and the Communists and if you
were to get rid of every single queer if
you got rid of every single gay every
single lesbian every single bisexual
every single trans person if you got rid
of all of them in a generation or two
they would reappear because they're a
part of us they're a part of humanity
they're a part of all of us they just
exist they are they are part of the
human experience yeah but I think that
chart you shared with the left-handed
thing yeah if Christians and Muslims
start dominating they're going to be
repressed right so the the idea is it's
like basic math we saw this in 2000
liberals were having 1.45 kids and
conservatives having 2.01 kids so
conservatives write replacement levels
and liberals weren't 20 years later we
see slightly more for the first time
ever conservative gen zirs in some areas
gen Z is about according to Pew as
Progressive as Millennials in some areas
a little bit more Progressive in some
areas a little bit more conservative
which is shocking because every
generation was skewing more Progressive
this is likely due to the fact not like
I said not that children were like I'm
conservative now but can service have
more kids so it really doesn't matter
what your position is if your position
is less kids for the left and more kids
for the right so you think transgender
people should have more kids I would
love it if trans people and LGBT people
had children and families
that's my personal morality but the end
result is there is one faction that is
pro-abortion unrestricted and in favor
of practices which result in a
substantial rate of sterilization for
children conservatives be it Muslim or
Christian or Jewish don't do these
things and so the future is very
obviously going to be an abrahamic
conservative country yeah but we need a
more scientific religion in the future
this is another two-hour conversation
maybe let's let's read some super chats
and then we'll uh we'll try to get the
members only q a straight to the Q a and
uh
I'll try and find some good uh good
super chat questions just to make sure
Carly says as a woman who's had an
abortion and given birth later in life
this man needs to do some research but
he sure has some balls for having this
conversation on Tim cast well I respect
it absolutely I thought it was a good
conversation the search TV
Lance yeah what is it YouTube dot slash
TV yeah uh everywhere social media is
sold at the surf's TV if you want to
hear my musings and I I will add that
well uh I do distinctly disagree with uh
most of the takes of the people on this
panel they've been very friendly and
very nice to me and they put me in a
nice hotel and uh Ian is uh is just as
friendly in real life as everyone led
him to believe you dude let me let me
here's one from Barbie dog he says
please ask your guest if he feels the
same about bodily autonomy bodily
autonomy with regards to the vaccines
uh yeah I think you should have the
right whether or not you want to take
the vaccine so you would disagree with
the vaccine mandate uh a forcible
vaccine mandate I mean for the purposes
of Freedom yes but it sucks if that's
one of those like it sucks but of course
I don't think people should be forced to
have to take a job against their will
like if if the government said in order
to go to the government mandate good
well no like a government mandated
vaccine program I disagree with in that
like every single human being is like
strapped down and like oh I don't want
to take it but you have to kind of thing
but you would be okay with like every
facet of society saying we require
vaccines oh when there was a vaccination
like um uh what was the word for it like
a segregation of people who were
vaccinated and unvaccinated well like
you oppose the government holding you
down and vaccinating it yes I think
you'd have a choice whether you should
do that but other people have it should
have a choice whether or not they get
sick from you because you didn't
vaccinate yourself do you think the
government should be allowed to mandate
vaccines for public accommodation yeah
for certain things of course like we
already do that for hospitals you have
to be vaccinated if you're a nurse or a
doctor against a host of different
things for obvious medical reasons and I
think that serves an important purpose
so
same thing with the military the
military is mandatory vaccination for
the same reasons but so so your line is
bodily autonomy but not participation in
society well you can choose whether or
not to be a doctor you can choose
whether or not to be in the military
well I mean like going to a cafe or a
movie or something right well yeah but
I'm saying that there are certain things
where it makes sense from a scientific
standpoint where like if you're a
doctorate nurse yeah that probably issue
it depends if that is directly going to
have an impact on the broader Society if
people get sick but that means no bodily
autonomy no bodily autonomy up to a
point you can choose whether or not to
go to the movies that's your choice you
can choose whether or not to join the
military so that's my point right you
you don't agree with the government
holding you down but you do agree with
the government excising you from society
we already accept this the government
does that in a variety of ways already
right so the Limitless we already live
in Madison Square Garden for instance
had a vaccine requirement and I think
Joe Rogan had to refund tickets because
he's at the show before the requirement
sure and it was the government that
imposed the requirement on all the
businesses so the vaccine mandate
there's there's two ways to look at it I
think what they're asking is ostracizing
or exercising someone from society is a
vaccine mandate right using restricting
someone's ability you have an ability to
you have a choice to do it whether you
want to or not it's it's whether or not
you can have convenience and and
pleasure in society and it's it's
obviously a big inconvenience if you
don't get to go to see Madison Square
Garden Of course so but this is a this
is a by case basis as well right
government The Government Can pressure
you to do it you can take away for sure
privileges and access until you do it as
a matter of public safety we already
allow this the government does this in a
variety of ways for a ton of different
things I get concerned about that phrase
Public Safety because if another if
they're like this common cold is very
very contagious hey we have a vaccine
ready for it and I'm like you know let's
do some long-term studies vaccines are
can be very dangerous if they're not
studied properly
um so maybe that's another conversation
to have I think it's very important not
to let the medical industry govern us
well that's why we have a government
also this isn't all axiomatic right so
you could have the position that under
no circumstances would you ever support
the government mandating vaccines you
could be of the position that you would
be in favor of it but just not for a
disease with the infection and mortality
rate that covet has there's a lot of
different approaches
so uh Admar says this guest looks like
the kid of Brendan Fraser and Justin
Long
my entire life it's a running meme
um Tim I gotta I got I gotta I gotta
read this one I love how they call me a
kid by the way hey just so everyone
knows I'm the oldest person in this room
I'm 44. okay never mind
I gotta read it I gotta read this one
this is important 1776 as life says what
is a woman
yeah a woman is an adult human female
easy enough I agree with that so trans
women are not women oh absolutely
trans women aren't female they're male
no they're female so they have female
gametes and whatnot oh this is actually
very uh interesting do you want to talk
about gummies so in in embryonic
development uh when you have two Guy
meets obviously the sperm of the egg
they combine right usually it's a 23rd
chromosome the x-axis or the XY that is
going to determine whether or not
someone becomes a male or a female but
that's not always the case there are
exceptions to this known as people with
differences of sexual development dsds
or intersex people like there could be
other combinations uh it's it's on a
conservative estimate 0.6 to two percent
of the population there is more intersex
people in America than there are
redheads so there's a lot of intersex
people and that's if you go with the two
percent
Sheamus is completely right but I do
want to add one really interesting about
this being a female is a male so here's
here's the neatest part there are
individuals who have X Y chromosomes
which is normally what is going to be a
male right you develop it's not the only
Factor by the way it's a pull push and
pull with hormones and other stuff like
that but there are people who have X Y
chromosomes so if you looked at their
bones years into the future and you
analyze them they would be genetically
male but they have a specific condition
that suppresses testosterone which makes
them develop 100 like women we are all
templates we are all templates and based
on hormones uh the expression of gender
and and different factors we turn in One
Direction or the other towards more male
certain drugs don't affect men and women
the same way exactly and that's that's
the the interesting thing but we can
hijack this entire process if we take
hormones so if we take testosterone
estrogen we suddenly can have traits
that are more feminine or masculine to
redistribute but it doesn't the gross
the growth of breasts the length of hair
all that kind of stuff so there are
socialist wants to redistribute the fat
so here's here's the here's what I'm
getting to is uh I think it was in 1993
they passed along the united states that
required clinical testing to be done on
men and women separately because women
are affected by drugs differently and
they found that painkillers for instance
didn't work on women and so these male
doctors were all like these women are
sissies they can't take the pain when in
reality it's like the painkillers
weren't working yeah so uh and they also
in these studies found that yeah no uh
the the differences between males and
females you can't change through
hormones for instance fast twitch muscle
fiber uh collagen in the skin prenatal
testosterone the impact that won't
change from later in life taking
hormones so a male's not a female
female's not a male gen sex is bimodal I
think if you ask it's it's genuinely not
in any anything it is totally is totally
is we've we've gone we've gone from the
left saying that sex is bimodal to not
rejecting it or or are you just
incorrect I think I'm incorrect hold on
do you know what bimodal means I don't
know it means that intersex people exist
and that there's an overlap between the
two bell curves
oh sorry yes you're totally right this
is I I'll take a big L right there so
that that means that yeah 97 of females
will have statistically average female
traits yes you're correct the reason I
wanted to jump on that though is because
you're saying that just because you have
X Y chromosomes that means by definition
you're male that's not true
okay do you know about the South African
beauty queen where she is by Yeah by all
there's a documentary on her by all
accounts if you saw her you'd be like
this is just a gorgeous beautiful woman
she has all the the parts of a woman
she's breasts she has you know vagina
all that stuff but she is intersex and
her chromosomes are X Y so if you looked
at her genetics she's genetically male
and so this isn't but but accepting that
you know we want we want rights for all
people including intersex people it
doesn't change the fact that they make
up a relatively small portion of society
zero zero point six to two percent so
can I can I make it so a biological male
cannot become a biological female uh no
no no no one is saying they can no no no
no no you just did no I didn't not
whatsoever I see what a woman was yes an
adult human and I says a trans woman a
female he said yes I said a trans woman
is a woman and they absolutely are this
is not a god a woman is a female CIS
women and trans women are different and
trans women do not say that they're CIS
women they don't and that's what makes
them trans they're women yeah of course
because black women and white women are
different but they're both women but a
woman is a trans woman an assist women
are different but either woman is female
women an adult human female a trans
woman is male that was that's what makes
them trans they are not male I I just
want to make a woman is female they are
assigned a sign we we yeah you're signed
your gender at Birth yeah so we're only
we're only what is observed we're two
right we're two we're two super chatted
I feel like a trans woman is a man and a
trans man is a woman and they're both
you're both a trans woman and a man
together
they don't see them I think the the
point about like intersex or some people
having chromosomes that don't exactly
match up with their sex is not the
problem for or is not a problem for what
is termed the gender binary by the left
so I think the best way to define sex is
based on a gametes you know the role a
person plays in reproduction and Tim
mentioned gametes and not chromosomes so
I would Define a female as someone whose
reproductive Anatomy is ordered towards
gestation and then a male is someone
whose reproductive Anatomy is ordered
towards insemination right operating in
the operating phrase there is order
towards right because someone can have
an issue with their reproductive Anatomy
but it's still ordered towards something
and recognizing the bimodal nature of
human sex meaning that overwhelmingly
there's two big trees with a slight
overlap in the middle well even that
overlap in the middle the vast majority
of people who are are intersex are
basically clearly a member of One sex
but with some feature that appears
differently yeah yeah but with one one
or two features that's a huge problem
that's a massive but but but people who
you genuinely can't tell are talking
extremely extremely rare I I I don't
like the argument that we should reform
society around you you know very very
small minorities other than just protect
the rights of so if we're talking about
you know the issue of biological males
going into women's bathrooms or
something like that you have an issue of
the civil rights of females versus the
civil rights of trans women and that's
where the conflict comes into play yeah
but the conflict there is pretty easy
the majority of people who abuse women
in bathrooms is CIS men let's go after
CIS men for that
well I think the solution is easy just
single stall bathrooms like I don't know
also connects the bathroom's here on
gendered but I want to say everyone at
home if you didn't know that they don't
gender the bathrooms here there's
there's no signal rooms yeah that's just
that's the way the world religion has
always been single you don't have a
right to be comfortable that's not one
of your rights you could deal with it
you know deal life is weird and
uncomfortable sometimes that's I don't
know but but the bigger question is in
general when it comes to the the
transgender men in sports and things
women in sports and things like that is
the rights of females versus the rights
of trans people and and who gets uh
supplanted
right and so my answer to the bathroom
problem would be the majority of women
who are abused in bathrooms are abused
by CIS men and so that we should be if
we want to protect women and go after
abusers go after CIS Men Who attack
women in bathrooms but how do you tell
the differences
that trans women are more often the
victims of sexual and physical abuse
than they are the perpetrators but that
didn't actually address what I said
right it's like females and trans women
who gets supplanted if females say we
want a space free from males period
then should they have their rights
protected in having a safe space or
should trans women say no we actually
get access to the space do do trans men
take away from your experience do they
supplant to you as a man me personally I
don't care right me too in fact trans
men make my experience is way more
interesting you haven't answered the
question because you're saying
supplanting their experience right
you're taking away from women there are
women right now yes who are saying
they're biological females saying we do
not want biological males in our space
so should Blair white be allowed to go
in that bathroom I think Blair white
should go in the bathroom where Blair
white appears to to to to fit in so why
does she why does she get a pass because
she's very passing is that why I I'm not
talking about my my view is Buck Angel
should go in the men's room and Blair
white should go in the women's room but
they disagree with that she's
technically a biological male I think
Claire white agrees with what I just
said yes but you're taking my position
and and good for you that's woke as
hell yeah
I don't know if you watch the show it's
not progress I've always had that
opinion it's basis hell yeah but
I've always had that opinion
do you think Blair white should have to
go into a man's bathroom yeah yeah
absolutely but I I think that just
causes more because because well I don't
want to say anything that's going to get
Tim's YouTube channel taken down let's
go to the members only Show and Sheamus
can then say all of his nasty Catholic
things well yeah all right everybody
here's what's going to happen I'm I'm uh
sorry sorry we didn't get to the super
chats I I genuinely apologize we just
this is what happens we go off right
we're gonna go to the members only chat
we're gonna do audience questions smash
the like button if you if you would like
and head over to timcast.com become a
member
we're going to do the members only so
that Sheamus can say naughty words or
whatever yeah uh but before we go that's
what they call the truth follow the show
at timcast IRL on Instagram you found me
personally Tim Kess Lance you want to
shout anything out uh thank you so much
for uh watching me and listening to my
radical leftist Marxist agenda uh if you
want to see me anywhere else on the
internet go to everywhere uh social
media sold at the surf's TV that's at
the search TV and also shout out to the
leftist mafia who's watching this right
now love all of you
my name is Seamus Coughlin uh what I'm
shouting out is the Saint Joseph Novena
that I'm praying right now we're on day
four you can find that on my Twitter I
pinned it we're praying for the working
class in this country in this time of
deep economic turmoil for The Unborn and
for our enemies people we disliked
people who got uh fired from fight still
in Mulvaney and that our country will
return to God and I am Ian Crossland I
agree with you the country will return
to God I think it is very important that
we although we will focus on the things
we are saying Focus very much on the way
we are saying them and find a way to
communicate with people that we may
disagree with that's the root of empathy
and uh communication and the unification
of humanity moving forward thank you
very much for coming Lance that was
really awesome and Tim you're a badass
so are you Sheamus not search though no
surges no it's not just like a
wavelength uh yeah uh that was quite
intense
um well we still got more we're gonna do
this members on the uncensored thing
where Sheamus is gonna go Super Saiyan
yeah why are you putting this all on me
because you're the it's never going
Super Saiyan
[Applause]
all right uh Serge uh yeah I'm surge.com
on Twitter uh this is gonna be
interesting let's go and uh the last
thing I'll say is for those they're just
you know they aren't going to be at the
members show uh Lance this is one of the
best episodes I think we've ever done um
I think these are these are the best
conversations because we obviously clash
and view the world differently but this
is where the the conversation it needs
to happen for for anyone's views to
evolve or to at least understand what
the other person thinks we're gonna go
to timcast.com go to the front page
it'll be live in a few minutes we'll try
to make it quick and then we'll be up
and then Shameless will say naughty
words thanks for hanging out why do you
put
cheers